foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the premier online speed chess
tournament a knockout filled with
tension drama quick tactics and shocking
moments oh my gosh for the last seven
years and counting the best Blitz and
bullet players in the world have flocked
to chess.com to prove their worth at
this format
excitement rains every year with major
upsets and intense battles
this year 12 invitees and four
qualifiers face off for the title dozens
have tried but only two have ever worn
this Crown Magnus makes it look easy
wins the speed test championship
in a row who will be this year's Blitz
King it's time to find out
[Music]
welcome to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase
[Music]
and we welcome everybody to the speed
Chess Championship presented by coinbase
another incredibly exciting match for us
today between alireza farouza and
Dimitri on draken we are excited to
welcome coinbase as a presenting partner
of the speed Chess Championship and we
are excited to welcome Grandmaster Amman
Hamilton alongside me Grandmaster Daniel
nariditsky in the studio to bring this
match to you I'm on good afternoon
morning evening wherever you are good
afternoon to you
that's right I am finding myself in
Canada right now Daniel but we welcome
all our viewers around the world because
this is going to be an insanely exciting
match we have uh honestly two incredible
talents but two very very different
players in terms of their play style and
generations you know the list goes on
and on my favorite matchups are
definitely the Battle of different
generations and okay let's not overstate
the case here Dimitri on draken hasn't
hit 35 yet uh but Ali Reza farouza
hasn't hit 25 so what we have for you
today starting at 1pm Eastern yes that
is eight minutes from now folks alireza
farusha the Phenom the 2800 is taking on
Russian Grandmaster Dimitri on draken or
Dima as I will be referring to him
throughout the commentary but first
let's look at the bracket let's see some
of these names that have been competing
in the SEC as we zoom in uh having a
hard time making out these names uh I'm
on I you don't really see them on
tournament cross tables very often do
you yeah I'm just uh I mean one of them
Carlos and kind of familiar but I mean
who are we kidding here Daniel this is a
literally a compilation of the best
players in the world and that's why this
SEC has become the Marquee online event
absolutely and the winner of today's
matchup faces Grandmaster Wesley so who
alongside Hikaru Nakamura and nihal
sarin have already taken care of their
first round uh business but man Wesley's
gonna be a brutal matchup but you can't
think about that you have to think about
winning today's matchmon
yeah one step at a time I and truthfully
I think these guys are all star-studded
professionals they don't really think
like oh yeah I'd like to face you know
Magnus in the final that'd be nice they
really do take it one step at a time
which is keeping the emotions in check
which I think you have to in a speed
chess like this you most certainly do
you have to keep your emotions in check
and you have to accumulate
the maximum number of points okay let's
go over to the rules
and we have
one point per win Alpha point for drama
if anybody doesn't know the SEC format
yet then something's wrong with you yeah
I mean it's like this is the format but
it's also a little bit of Common Sense
too I think the most uh interesting
thing is the the tie breaks there uh
mostly because I'm secretly hoping yes
I'll say it for a tie break
me too uh in case of a tie break uh as
we have 90 minutes of five plus one an
hour of three plus one 30 minutes of one
plus one you might think a tie break is
impossible but no it is very much
eminently possible and in the event of a
tie break we will have four games of
bullet to play I'm on I always say this
when I introduce the format uh these 30
minutes of one plus one don't pay
attention to the fact that there's less
bullet to play than there is five or
three the bullet always has the capacity
to change the outcome of the match
yeah I mean speed chess we test the
players in every time control that's why
I think truthfully this is one of the
most Fair formats and you really you
finish the match feeling like if you
lost it you know you just weren't the
better player that day you have the
increment so it's not complete Flags
nonsense uh we might see some but
truthfully the the best chess tends to
win
well we will see if generation Reza or
generation Dimitri will take the cake
today as we head on over to our Deloitte
analytics we are thrilled this year to
have Deloitte a leader in their field as
an official partner for the speed Chess
Championship their dedication to
Excellence aligns perfectly with the
ethos of Chess and with the chess.com
mission to grow the game and the sport
of chess the Lord is the official Data
Insights partner of the SCC and now
let's dive into our Deloitte game
analytics and there's a lot of analytics
to go through first of all what puzzles
well not puzzles me the most to Metron
drinking is a beast but look at their
Blitz Head to Head it's all tied up at
22 and even their Bullet Head to Head
they've played quite a bit of bullet
we've got a large sample size and it's
close as hecamon
yeah it really is and I wonder as I'm
about to say this for the hundredth time
if this is the person I say this the
most uh in chess that Dimitri on draken
is so underrated uh underrated maybe
with his ELO but also by the people like
just a name that always seems to do well
uh you know he never has flashy
performances but he's so solid he always
competes with the best in the world so
yes this will be a closer match Than
People expect
yeah Dimitri and draken is kind of a
Workhorse right he he goes behind the
scenes and then he always seems to score
in the top three of any tournament that
he plays in so do not sleep on Dima and
do not sleep on page two of our Deloitte
game analytics because we have some more
interesting stats for you we've got the
players ratings uh those are pretty high
numbers I'm looking into bullet rating
35-21 I thought that was back in the
teams that's actually a reading that's
back in the days of hyperinflation I'm
on I mean I know paper talk that's 40
nowadays but man 35-21 that is quite a
number
yeah it's it's incredible and obviously
these players both both well into the
3000s and I feel like once you're in
that territory I mean there's just one
word for you and you're just freaking
strong at that point like it's so hard
to determine uh you know who's a little
bit better here and there and that's
ultimately what this match is going to
paint a picture of today who's a little
bit better in what time control
and it's interesting alireza is the more
experienced SCC player he's got about
double the number of SEC games as his
opponent so even though he's younger by
age he's older by SCC experience and uh
according to smarter chess his
experience his higher rating and his
Superior performance in recent Blitz
events will contribute to a blowout says
smarter chess and just be very clear
who's saying this uh the smarter Fest
prediction calls for a seven point
Victory by alireza farusa moreover Amman
it calls for victory in every one of the
three segments uh which
Dimitri and draken will have to
counteract if he wants a chance in this
match
yeah he will but I do feel that if
Dimitri wins this match it's probably
not going to be the reverse it's
probably not going to be a blowout for
him I think that when when Dima wins
these matches is usually close matches
he just he has that grit he out muscles
the opponent stamina so I think it'll be
a close one if he wins but for ruja even
against the best in the world he can
just go on a tear like he can he could
literally just win 10 games in a row and
you're like wait that was a 3 000 that
you just played
yeah Ali Reza definitely has that turbo
mode and if he turns it on there's very
few who can stand in his way I think
it's pretty uncontroversial with full
due respect to Dimitri who is a beast to
say that a victory by andrekin would be
perhaps our first upset of the SCC I
think that's largely incontrovertible
and it's incontrovertible according to
the community at large 89 of whom chose
the number three seed to win the match
4866 out of man I'm not trying to add
589 to that amount but it's been a while
since you started digging and I was like
okay yeah go for it you finished that
thought
um I think the most interesting thing
that I noticed about these players is
that I can't believe I'm going to say
this Danielle but neither one has
actually been passed in the first round
like what kind of statement is that I
think of these names I think oh yeah a
couple rounds in finals performance but
we're actually gonna see one of these
players make it to the next round for
the first time
that's crazy that's very hard to wrap
one's head around especially given
alireza farusha's experience level in
the SEC so he's played a lot of years
but this is this is Ali Reza farusha's
World Cup as it is to Magnus right this
is the one tournament where he's kind of
struggled to get past uh the first round
the first couple of rounds now we know
what happened with Magnus in the World's
Cup didn't we so let's see if Ali Reza
farusha takes a page out of Carlson's
performance and if this is the SCC where
the exciting youngster delivers for the
first time
that's right and of course we start with
the five minute portion there's that
increment throughout all portions here
so you know a little bit less flagging
but five plus one is actually an area
where smarter chess was saying that fuja
has a noticeable Advantage so that's one
portion where you could see on Drake and
just get off to a strong start and
immediately kind of flip the script on
uh the analytics so to speak
and the script that we've seen thus far
in our first couple SEC matches I mean
aronian aronian Wesley was a crazy first
three games and then largely a blowout
the rest of the match you want to avoid
I talk about the Three-Point Rule if you
fall behind by three points or more
that's when you get into that territory
when you start really digging yourself
into a hole and feeling like you can't
come back you want to avoid that
happening as an underdog if you're
Dimitri on draken the five minute
portion is critical the first 45 minutes
of the five minute portion are extra
critical you want to set the tone you
want to show that you can compete with
alireza in the opening on the clock and
we will see if he has it in and the
games are about to begin
and you know that the interesting thing
that I always look for Daniel when these
SCC matches start is I find that it's a
little bit of a cat and mouse game both
guys are kind of testing out openings
seeing what works and at this high level
the players are so quick to adapt and
adjust so if they try an opening and you
know there's an immediate problem a good
line from the opponent they'll be happy
to switch it up so I always I'm looking
forward to the five minute portion
because I feel that it's a little bit
experimental players aren't sure what
they're gonna go with the whole match
and so you really see a wide variety of
openings and players when they find
something that works they're going to
stick with it yeah we get a lot of data
about the Arc of the match from the
first couple of games and there's
opening repeaters in the SEC players who
choose their set of openings and then
stick to them the whole match and then
there's opening changer like Hikaru
Nakamura in the second category he can
play absolutely anything he will change
an opening at a moment's notice if
something doesn't work out and I
personally feel like the second strategy
is likelier to lead to success but all
of that aside seat belts fast and folks
the next SCC match is underway with
alireza deploying a rue Lopez and a
schliemann the first surprise of the day
that's fun I mean uh yeah you think game
one I was just talking about
experimental I think this is the
definition of experimental
okay Queen E2 is not a mistake let's get
one thing out of the way that's one of
the main moves and the point is to
prevent black from castling easily
because that would run into Queen C4
check forking the bishop and the King
but it has Ali Reza been take well he's
definitely been taken off guard and
perhaps a pretty astute opening Choice
here in the early going
mm-hmm you know there's something about
this opening just strategically that's
always made so much sense to me for the
black pieces actually to be able to play
F5 take and just play D6 Castle it's
like is there any better feeling than
castling and your Rook is already set up
with you know it's got like the college
fund that the parents started a while
ago easily set up for Success it's got
the slush funds you know it's got It's
got the restaurant yeah for sure and I
feel like the schliemann is a very
misinterpreted opening people think of
it in the same category as you know the
king's Gambit as some sort of gimmicky
line but from a positional standpoint it
is quite sound if if if black and Castle
King side and get the king to safety and
that is why whites play uh is often
aimed at developing that initiative
before black can get a chance to
consolidate we saw Dimitri trade the
knights there with nighty Forum on uh
that Bishop can be chased away with the
move C3 and then white snipe from D2 I
think will likely jump out either to C4
or perhaps go the other way to F3
that's right yeah basically just gaining
time hitting the bishop with Tempo and
you've got this weird Bishop on B5 it
looks actually really silly but you
would be surprised how annoying it is to
not be able to play the move D6 here and
it's not yet certain whether you want to
spend times on A6 and C6 because
Danielle when you start moving too many
pawns you create weaknesses in your own
position
and there we have the direct consequence
of black not being able to play D6 I
mean you would kill to control the F5
Square as it stands you probably have to
just castle and bite the bullet and
allow the move Knight F5 and then you
have to be very careful where you put
your queen because you don't want to
walk into Bishop C4 uh you might want to
drop it back to E8 and then try to
reroute it toward G6 so the engine seems
to think that black has solved his
problems but from a practical
perspective Dimitri needs to make a
couple more careful moves before I'd say
that the opening was a true success
yeah and it's so unfair it's like the
engine's like oh yeah actually you've
solved all your problems you're fine and
this is actually right when it feels
like the problems are just mounting and
becoming present so uh yeah a bit of a
different view there but as you guys can
see engine eval you know right right
around uh even so we're still very much
in an opening uh battle here with both
players definitely an ollie Reza trying
to find ways to keep the fire burning
right because if the fire burns out then
the fire starts on the other side you
know black will start operating on the
king side and that is why we see
allureza playing with such a sense of
urgency I like the move Queen F7 here uh
because Bishop C4 can be met with D7 D5
and the Knight on F5 is likely to lose
its uh the support of the pawn
so tactically that move works out for
black
that's right and yeah of course after
Queen F7 forgive me for looking at the
nonsensical Bishop to H6 it's like
please take me I I got something in
store for you Queen F7 Bishop H6 but I'm
not sure it really works
I Can't Tell You Why off the top of my
hand it doesn't really work because if
you defend the G7 Pawn I can take it
anyway and clear the H6 Square for my
knight so 98 is definitely not the
answer but I think that's precisely what
Dimitri was afraid of and alireza
immediately drops this Knight back to G3
yeah is this like my general feeling is
black wants to just go King h8 like
there's so many Bishop C4s why have them
stress you out you know calculation wise
King h8 seems like a move that you're
gonna have to play in this game
eventually why not do it now
and Dimitri can repeat moves but I agree
completely King h8 is kind of a
no-brainer in this position and he's
done it
and now I'm starting to really like
Black's position one of the drawbacks is
of the queen on E6 is that it does block
the natural development of the bishop
but that Queen is gonna move anyway he's
gonna decide where to put it again I
feel like his Queen has gotten attacked
just a countless number of times and
queen G4 is a great move
it is like imagine uh after the capture
all of Black's pieces are working
attacking that pawn uh low-key the best
piece in the position might be that
Bishop on B6 Daniel like it's just
sitting there it's probably the best
place a bishop can be because it's
exerting the pressure on F2 but from
such a safe distance That's The Power of
Bishops
it's amazing that we're 14 moves in and
black still hasn't pushed the d-pawn and
yet his position is completely healthy
everything is fine once he does play D6
I feel like if anybody is to be
preferred it's black white can grab the
queen and then go Knight H1 but Knight
H1 in almost any position is not a good
sign
yeah I think I think Knight H1 is a move
that even if you know it might be all
right there's a little you lose a little
face with your opponent they kind of
look at you funny like ah I got you to
play Knight H1
exactly I mean
Ali Reza is
down to two minutes this is a hard
decision to make you would really love
to play F3 and fix your Pawn instruction
chase the Knight away instead he
sacrifices a pawn what a drastic
decision by farusha who's trying to open
the file and guess what he is trying to
punish black or delaying his Queen side
development so after Knight takes E3 F
takes E3 Dimitri just decides not to
engage with that at all very practical
decision
yeah I I almost want to bring up the
analysis board just for a sec to show uh
what might have happened there because
um you know of course Knight takes E3
Pawn takes E3 we're all wondering like
what the heck this is just a free Pawn
King H1 but think about how you have to
play with black here because their
Checkmate threats there's a rook hanging
let's say you take the Rook takes this
is exactly why delaying that development
can be really difficult and and yeah I
think this is tough to play for blacks I
don't blame Dimitri for totally totally
I mean The Rook can get to F7 as well as
f8 and then the Knight jumps to F5 so
this is scary right you're not developed
and it's so easy when you have the
engine evil to say ah there's nothing
you know this is a paper Tiger but when
you're playing farusha all of your
enemies get blown up in proportion
instead we have I would argue a largely
equal end game the pawn structure is
kind of interesting in the sense that
black and gold C6 and D5 at some point
but that's also associated with a great
deal of risk if you play C6 at the wrong
moment then you create a massive
weakness on D6 so my guess is Dimitri is
going to keep the status quo maybe go
Bishop E8 Bishop F7 uh and try to take
the Bishops off the board but Ali Russ
has got to be relieved because there was
a point at which I thought that he was
on the cusp of getting into trouble
that's right and uh Bishop E3 like I
give him so much credit for that move
because quite literally I don't even
know it would if it would be on my like
radar of candidate moves Bishop E3 uh
you know hanging upon even just giving
up the bishop but such a a great move
because you're almost playing against
your opponent a little bit it's like a
psychological move hey take my take this
Free Pawn I'm offering you I'm happy to
go into the complications and he just
knew that andrekin is not willing
without question and furniture with
another important decision I liked the
idea of getting the king closer to the
queen side so that your minor pieces uh
don't stumble over each other on the C
file now King D3 would have threatened
to move B4 so Dimitri does play C6 the
middle decision and an even more
committal decision to push in the center
but will this backfire him on because
that Rook on C5 is now really
uncomfortable yeah it's about to be
trapped uh the move d4 almost needs to
happen but you know maybe there's like a
knight D1 Knight B2 Knight C4 there
there are some weak pawns here in
Black's camp that was the missed
Opportunity by Ali Reza I thought well
Rook A5 is literally forced otherwise B4
traps The Rook that Knight on E2 is now
kind of neither here nor there alireza
might have to play up four to try to
justify its placement and he does but
the E4 Pawn is now itself a major
weakness and Dimitri should probably go
rookie 8 here and aim at that E4 Pawn so
that he's ready to capture it when the
e-file opens up
yeah there's some like uh very
aggressive ways to play where you go
like Knight G4 and after Pawn takes
maybe C5 basically solidifying this Pawn
chain and I do think there are some end
games that could happen here where black
is just much better because take a look
at that Bishop yes it's holding
everything but it's also not doing
anything except you know defensive
duties
no question and Ellie Rose is down to 30
seconds Dimitri still has a minute I see
SC solidifies the D4 Pawn C5 is a very
safe positional move now he's probably
ready to take on F4 and exert direct
pressure on the E4 Pawn the bishop can
come out to C6 which is why you see
farusha all hands on deck defensively
but that's not a great sign for his
position that Knight on G3 has no active
prospects
yep obviously he wants to play Rook F1
but you know as long as uh Dimitri keeps
the f file like the F7 square is
probably the most dangerous one I do
think he's got a good position here Rook
f8 also looks like it holds everything
and it will be Black's response to Rook
F1 exactly and now white is that a bit
of a dead end now like Reza is still
trying to stir the pot as much as he can
on the king side Dimitri can lock things
up with H5 but instead he's trying to
trade Rooks black should really try to
play this for a win here the time
situation alireza slightly worse he
needs to tread very carefully to avoid
losing the first game
that's right and this Knight if it makes
it to E5 I'm not sure the prospects are
gonna ever get better than that for the
night hits the bishop covers F7 great
block eating Square
I like C3 a lot open up the position
make it a little easier to play that one
second increment obviously coming in so
handy right now but Dimitri he does get
his Knight to E5 he can do it now
he's thinking about something there it
is but what now how do you actually
progress and maybe he wants to play it
solid and play it safe
yep that is if I you know if I'm
thinking of Dimitri that's so his play
style right there and at this point it
might be the reason why we don't see
this pressed much further
yeah and alira does a great job getting
that knight from the King side to the
center and now trading off Black's not
using some tactics alireza is making
some strides here he is yeah this is
really great for for white I think
nothing serious uh if the Rooks trade
off I I still think
um you know White's got some decent
chances uh just because of these double
pawns and now the bishop comes out to C4
covering the F7 Square
Bishop D7 G5 G5 oh yeah
and alireza has to give up a pawn in
order to avoid getting his Rook trap but
G5 is Unstoppable now
yeah and actually he had to make room
Rook C4 there oh and Bishop E6 would
have won the game for black because it
would have covered the Rooks Escape
Square now Ali has incredible some
chances but he shouldn't be able to
survive this Amman no this this is
really kind of look at these pawns all
Targets black Bishop is placed perfectly
you still need it feels like if you blow
on White's position it's going to
collapse maybe G4 that forces a pawn end
game but is that pawn end game actually
winning apparently it's not
oh my God apparently this is strong
it's like brutal you you do everything
right you're up a pawn you have the
opposition King D3 you have to play King
D3 to meet King C6 with King C4 black
has no way to triangulate and black has
no way to push B5 without sacking the
pawn dead draw crazy believable
oh big Miss by Dimitri he's still trying
he's maneuvering and sidestepping and
dancing but nope
yeah okay this also also works
yeah I wonder if it was actually
necessary because King C4 there was King
C6 and B5
A4 yeah it's like a nice little sense of
humor by Dimitri that's right because at
this point even if black wins this pawn
it would be a draw anyway
um which these players are well aware of
and wow I feel like we got to see a
little bit of everything ultimately
ending in a draw in game one but we saw
an interesting opening remarkable sack
by alireza and then chances for both
sides at the end there yeah and Dimitri
was winning in one move he rushed the
move G5 which you cannot blame him he
could have covered the Rooks Escape
square and that Rook would have gotten
trapped by force
amazing job by Ellie Reza defending for
a very long time right things kind of
got out of control for him when he
pushed F4 but he kept his composure and
this is one of his greatest strengths
and Blitz when there's a one second
increment alireza can basically Play
Perfect chess on his last couple of
seconds or an indefinite period of time
yeah I mean that that skill alone will
will take you very very far in the world
of online chess yes it will and in the
world of title Tuesdays and SCC matches
you have a um you know that Carlsbad
kind of structure here and uh I guess a
more interesting more aggressive line
this bishop D6 you're kind of saying
okay yeah I get it you're pinning me but
I'm just gonna defend with the Knight
don't need to play Bishop V7 and I'm
gonna get my Queen off the d8 square so
it's kind of fully ignoring this bishop
G5 idea it's amazing how opening
Fashions change 15 20 years ago it was
considered anathema uh to bring that
dark skirt Bishop out to D6 you were
supposed to put it on E7 this was like
eating cereal in the morning like you
just don't you know there's just some
things you do not do but stockfish you
know you don't nobody cares anymore what
the Old Masters did or what the old
textbooks say all you care about is what
the top engine recommendation is and the
engine almost exclusively recommends not
only putting your dark Square Bishop on
D6 but also bringing your light skirt
Bishop out and putting it on E6 building
this nice little sixth ranked cocoon
with your Bishops making it hard for
white access important squares for his
own minor pieces
yep and there was a little bit of an
idea there Knight B5 which is a classic
you know trick and reason why you have
to be careful when your Queens on C7 is
black but think of it it's like Bishop
G5 Black Goes Bishop D6 and white says
uh hang on Bishop H4 Bishop G2 let me
get that piece off the board for you so
yeah Theory definitely developing there
indeed and the game developing white
kind of massaging the queen side there
repositioning the queen of B3 alireza
somehow surprisingly sees the attack on
the B7 pawn and he's really getting
better before her very eyes isn't he
yeah I know it's it's really remarkable
but you know as an up-and-coming Talent
we expect nothing less
and will we expect G5 here chasing that
Knight out of f4 that is not out of the
question it's not like white has a mast
you know an impressive number of pieces
on the king side and can really punish
black for that I would consider I would
seriously flirt with the idea of going
G5 here and just get that Knight out of
f4 force it back to E2 and maybe start
expanding on the king side with like
King G7 and eventually H5 H4
uh Daniel you flirt
I know you yeah so inappropriate to be
doing this during commentary man it
really feels like G5 does have that air
of like it's slightly inappropriate but
you both know you're thinking about it
exactly like it's it almost feels like a
violation of the basic code of ethics to
push you know a king Side Pawn in the
Carlsbad and opening yeah as positional
as the Queen's gamma decline but this is
exactly how uh I think the conception of
Black's proper play in this line has
changed uh from you're just supposed to
wait it out so you actually can't attack
on the king side here and G5 might
essentially be forced because white
wants to play F3 and E4 but instead Ali
Reza taking the quieter approach
dropping his Bishop back to E6 from once
it came oh no yep oh no don't oh no
don't say it say it ain't so oh no
yeah I think you got to keep playing
this um especially the move Bishop E6
kind of tells me that he wanted to keep
playing it initially
um another move by the way that's just
been on my mind is the movie A5 it's
just a useful move sometimes Queen B4
um but just gaining a bit of space uh on
the on the queen side there as well
he sticks his Knight instead on e4 A5
definitely a move that you have in your
kind of data Bank of useful moves 94 is
often met with Knight df6 just kind of
establishing a presence in the center
white has to watch out for the fork on
D2 that is very very commonly missed uh
in related Blitz Games
yup and very commonly missed by me as
well and by me don't worry I'm also in
that category
yes of Rook D1 you know takes care of
that and obviously develops the The Rook
as well uh not a bad move but I will say
like to your point yeah Knight F6 feels
like a nice achievement for black
especially because he's got the D5 score
now that can be used as
I don't know if I'd call that an outpost
but perhaps just a good Square for that
the position is equal and alireza has to
figure out which Knight he's actually
capturing because he takes F3 and F
takes G2 will keep the position open and
will damage White's King side slightly I
feel like that's in his style but he
likes the positional bind that he can
exert by putting a knight on D5
yeah I I think that we're definitely
equal here but my feeling is is that I
prefer black naturally
um there's ideas like H4 much later on
in the game once you stabilize
everything uh Knight to D5 but what
white wants to do is trade nearly
anything and I say that because look
he's even offering to have doubled
isolated a pawns just to trade the
Queens off and guess what I fully agree
with that decision it's such a great
move Queen A3 demonstrates such an
astute understanding of what's going on
the moment Ali Reza played H5 I think
his blood started to run cold did
Dimitri on draken's blood that is and he
said I need to get the ladies off the
board immediately because it doesn't
take long for black to ignite and this
is what I said earlier with a rook on E6
that can lift over to the king side it
takes two or three moves for black to
start the king side pressure and another
positive byproduct of the Queen's trade
yes optically the queen Side Pawn
structure looks terrible but look at
that B file white kid reposition a rook
to B1 the knight from D2 can jump over
to C5 and suddenly that pressure on
Black's Queen side pawns can become very
nasty yeah it's it's amazing but white
has such potential here with just you
know maybe doubling on the B file or
even having like Rook C2 Rook B1 Dual
Purpose you can double on either the b
or the C file A5 maybe A6 to loosen up
that c Pawn I do think that white has a
little more to play for here very
committal decision by alireza he might
have to follow that up with B6 and of
course if he plays B6 then Dimitri will
probably transition his play to the C
file so a good multi-purpose move here
would be would go Rook C2 you're
preparing to go either Rook B1 or Rook
C1 depending on how black arranges his
King side Queen Side Pawn
that's right and if you see B6 early it
invites Knight C4 uh whereas you know if
white plays Knight B3 it invites B6 so
both players want to time their moves
correctly here speaking of inviting B6
this is a wide open invitation please
play B6
okay he did your wish is by command it's
always a moment one one of the players
is correct here
um because when you both want the same
thing you know one of you is wrong
usually yeah and let's see who it is
well Dimitri blade Rook C5 very
confidently now he starts thinking Rook
B1
is true attempting move but black could
actually move the Rook from B8 let's say
to d8 and the B6 Pawn is Untouchable
because of the backward Fork on D7 maybe
this is the detail uh that has caught
Dimitri on draken off guard and caused
him uh to spend some time here
yep absolutely and I tell you if it was
whoa whoa yeah Rook E5
I don't know
97. white wants to win the E4 Pawn but I
think at this point now you're looking
at the C Pawn as a protected pass bond
in the position Diamond that was a very
very bad move by Dimitri he's he's
handed black a huge asset on the queen
side and with a pair of Rooks off the
board I'm on it's just much harder to
exert serious pressure on the B6 spawner
on the C6 Pawn which has turned from a
strength to a weakness in the span other
way around sorry for weakness to a
strength in the span of one move
and now Knight C5 hits the A4 Pawn
that's another weakness that you have to
reckon with I mean she can end up losing
material here
absolutely and one thing that's
underrated here is the double pawns
actually really uncomfortable for white
if a knight ever ends up on G4 don't
have Escape squares and F3 to kick the
night out is often hard to do because of
the E3 pawns so really dislike White's
Pawn structure on the king side and even
though it looks like it doesn't really
matter I think it does
Dimitri uses tactics to win the pawn
back but here comes that c Pawn choo
choo goes the train C5 look at that
Knight on A4 beautifully defending both
of the remaining queenside pawns they're
fully secured and now Black's Rook can
move to d8 it can occupy an open file
Knight C3 storm cloud starts to just
circle around White's entire Army here
yeah there's ideas like Knight C4 you
move the rook and yeah you can hang your
B6 Pawn because guess what it can't be
taken anyway black could just return and
and do a counter pin and that's very
well pointed out if white goes Knight E7
and Knight C5 black can just commonly
play Rook d8
and again using the fact that B6 is
Untouchable so that night I oh but now
Rook d8 there's Knight takes B6 which is
why I would have actually brought the
king maybe to the other side I would
have gone King H7 okay but he can go
Rook B8 here that's not a problem
yep now it's you know it feels like this
is the moment where both sides either
need to start pushing some pawns or
bring their kings like you know black
skin wants to enter The Fray and so does
whites but
um you know there's not gonna be time
for all that no entering The Fray for
whites King
yeah this looks really good for black
like very very simple right just bring
the king up to E6 and oh my gosh the
knight in the pond
man White's really taking some Backroads
it's like Google Maps tells you to take
the freeway and Dimitri is like new I
want to take the most obscure pathway
imaginable but this is going completely
off the rails King takes Pawn
does he want Rook D1 or something and
try to set up some sort of attack
against Black's King but there's no way
that can actually work no Knight C3
wow Rook B7 played immediately who's
setting up a mate on who here
well there's no threats rookie seven
King D King D6 so just go B5 push yeah
this is one of those situations where
the king can't move anywhere but all the
pieces that are preventing the king from
moving somewhere are being used so
there's nothing left to actually deliver
the check Knight takes A2 Rook D5 mate
would be a tragedy so I'll be Reza
whatever you do do not move the pony
from C3 it is integral toward ensuring
the safety of Black's King he's
investing most of his time here I think
he's trying to figure out which Pawn to
start with are we bloody beta one that's
insane oh my goodness no way
no what did we just see is that a
commentator curse for the ages and he
took 45 seconds on that move
and there's like no reaction from him
you will never see a bigger blunder at
that level truthfully you won't what in
the world
oh my goodness
I think that on Dragon was almost more
in shock than like he was processing it
more than
um Ali Reza there
I was debating as you know commentator I
like to we like to make the environment
welcoming for newer players right so I
was like I would I think it will not be
remiss for me to point out why you
cannot move the Knight I could not in my
wildest dreams imagine that he would
actually see this I
was almost like okay come on have some
respect for the viewers here for the
viewers yeah apparently I don't have
enough respect for alireza
I mean it really can happen to anyone as
we just saw there but uh I think this is
the first moment where we get to see can
Ali Reza completely shake that off
because he seemed unfazed as it happened
like in a state of total shock but we'll
we'll know right I think very soon
Daniel what he's really feeling yeah I
mean obviously in an SEC match you can't
dwell on these moments they happen and
this is just the start of the match so
objectively this is a very very small
deal actually but psychologically uh it
can kind of set the tone right these
blunders they Stack Up and the points
they rack up okay
um black racks up the E6 Pawn
well thank you hey I'm a poet in my
spare time didn't you know
let's see here what's going on now
Bishop I guess F7 this is always such a
weird moment because you want to go to
F7 but staying on this diagonal makes
more sense for you know Knight F5 pest
control as they say
Bishop D7 do not go Bishop H5 I feel
like anything I'd say the player is not
to do now Dimitri is going to go Bishop
H5 and blender 96 or what
no no it's not his term shortly
E7 calm pool collected
yeah what does white do here it's hard
for white to find a way to break down
that construction right the Knight on E5
super secure and the pawn chain on the
queen side B7 c65 I'm on Queen can come
out to B6 Black's position has a lot of
potential energy like the pieces are
really coming out nicely and maybe all
your resume plays F4 and forcibly chases
that Knight away but then black can grab
the bishop pair and maybe later on play
F6 F5 to open up the long diagonal for
the dark squared Bishop
yeah I think uh I think F5 is a definite
achievement because it's almost like
Black gets to play it before white gets
to occupy it good news
um but I don't know if white can just
jump in there straight away I was just
pointing out Queen B6 uh which hits the
Knight hits the B2 Pawn ends the Knight
and uh allows Rook A8 to EA
you could therefore try Knight F5 so
that Queen B6 doesn't come with the same
effect but something tells me Knight F5
just looks so flimsy black and play
Knight takes D3 although I guess so it
recaptures with the queen maybe alirez
is calculating something like this right
now because he's already invested over a
minute on this move
yeah Knight Knight F5 I don't think is
crazy because Knight D3 like the Knight
will take the bishop on G7 it seems it
seems reasonable I would play it in a
bullet game that's for sure Knight F5 is
my
Instinct here because if you if you
dilly dally for another two three moves
and black makes all the moves we're
talking about then the pressure in the
center can really really become nasty
that pawn on F3 is the source of a lot
of White's problems
and is Bishop F5 completely crazy here I
was thinking like Bishop F5 Queen B6
maybe Queen F2 because really if I'm
being honest I want these Bishops the
light Square Bishops off the board and
then me to play either Knight F5 or 96.
well I mean I wouldn't mind a filet
mignon medium well
with the little A1 Sauce in that metal
tin that they give you at steakhouses
my needs are great
there's a famous line from uh old Soviet
movie where one of the wistful
characters says I have the desire to buy
a house but not the opportunity I have
the opportunity to buy a goat but not
the desire so let's drink too uh our
desires always corresponding to our
abilities and alirez's desire made very
clear there as he does put a knight on
F5 we do have a mass trade but alireza
actually declining the queen trade in
that position
yeah I I honestly think it's just super
equal uh right now but White's position
is starting to look better and better to
me I actually like the decision to not
trade the Queens I I think that's uh
that's a pretty tough thing to see
because clean trade I mean it's totally
equal but now you know Bishop F4 Bishop
E3 I think if the Bishops trade the
black king being open exposed the way
that it is that is going to be the
difference and maybe andrekin should
seize this narrow window of opportunity
and play F4 trying to shut down the
proper development of White's Bishop he
does just that and vacating the F5
Square for his Queen so his next move
this could essentially be a pre-move
like Queen F5 could be Black's answer to
anything I'm expecting Bishop D2 after
Queen F5 we might get another equal end
game
yeah Queen F5 is a very good move like
you want to bring the Rook out and
there's no no more natural move than
than this the F4 Pawn is under attack
and I suppose if I'm looking like way
down the line I do like White's chances
in any game is that we will be able to
create a pass Pawn on the king side here
that's a good point and the long-term
weakness of the F4 Pawn
could cause some consternation now we
will get a trait of Rooks inevitably on
the e-file and the e-file itself is not
particularly essential because all of
the infiltration squares are safely
controlled by black skin
that's right
yep E8 E7 E6 and of course the E5 square
is covered by black so if we really you
know take note of the e-file there's
actually not many usable squares there
not a single one actually yeah two and
E1 are the only ones well he's got those
covered that's perfect exactly now
Dimitri is hesitating because he wants
to trade all of the roads what do you
make of that decision and then stick a
bishop on E5 and he's basically saying
yeah F4 is weak but you really can't get
to that point of your king
that's true
um I guess I would still go Bishop E1 I
mean yeah the bottom line is we're
trending towards equality here but
um Bishop E1 G4 I think if you don't
take that then you know Age 4 H5 quite
uh I kind of like swine's position I
can't tell you the amount of these types
of end games that I have lost against
Ali Raza and or Blitz matches one of his
most underrated strengths is his Magnus
Carlson ask ability to squeeze wins out
of equal end games in this particular
instance I think with two minutes on the
clock Dimitri has enough time to keep to
keep the balance as he expands on the
queen side puts his pawns on light
squares that's right but that's not
really the point of the move B5 he's
just sort of expanding and preventing an
eventual C3 C4
yep but it should be noted that you know
a simple move like instead of B5 A5 you
just wouldn't normally think of because
white plays A4 and the pawns for black
gets fixed on the same color as these
Bishops which means white will always be
attacking and black will always be
defending it does seem to me that
closing up the queen side like this is a
positional victory for white so he's
stitched up all of the squares that
black could use
uh to expand like C5 is impossible A5
and now why can it directs his attention
to the other side of the board
and put into practice the plan that you
talked about there's G4 there's on
Passat and I think black has to keep his
King active maybe just put it on F5 and
discourage white from making any further
gains on the king side and that's the
way to secure a draw
right yeah if if H5 I guess Pawn G4
would happen it feels like white has all
the chances because Black's pawns are
immobile but the you know the counter uh
argument is that all the pawns for black
are on light squares so that C3 Pawn
will be a clear Target that white always
has to watch over yeah there's no way
forward here I think because it's as
much of a magician as Ali Reza is okay
don't go King D4
that's right now I should be careful
what I say even A3 you know black plays
A4 and there are issues on the C1 Square
long term definitely A4 looks like a
very good investment for the future
you could play a takes before I don't
think it's essential because the
position is so locked up so like you
said we're trending toward a draw but
there's like a five percent chance that
something tactical happens and then the
position heats up but it's very unlikely
that's right yeah it really feels
natural to me to play A4 as black as
opposed to taking uh just because if you
take there's not really any weaknesses
white can leave the bishop on D4 and
cover the only one whereas now I feel
like C1 is something you have to watch
as well as C3
I think it's a classic positional drop
neither side can make any meaningful
progress if white plays G5 he merely
gives up the F5 squaring invites trouble
to his home
this is exactly it you've got one threat
and you've got another threat on E5 so
it's just difficult for either side to
do anything and both players are
extremely aware of this time to sign the
Peace Accords and Dimitri could stall
out you know the minute but at this
point as early in the match I really
don't think that a minute makes you know
enough of a difference so he is taking
his time and I think he's taking his
time to just gather himself prepare for
the next game decide what opening he's
playing those 10 15 seconds can really
help you reset and another great working
man's game by Dimitri on draken I mean
alireza is not showing anything
meaningful against the schliemann yeah
and I I think I was mentioning that with
sort of an experimental phase that's
something that he's gonna need an answer
to because if andrekin keeps getting
games like that he's gonna keep playing
that opening I'm going to predict
perhaps a transition to the Italian in
the next game by alireza of course these
top players are proud I'm on so they're
always unwilling to admit uh when they
have a certain Gap or a hole in their
preparation and I I think we have seen
SEC matches lost because of a player's
inability to just admit to themselves
listen
um yes I forgot to check this line I
don't remember my analysis let's switch
openings and get something I'm more
comfortable with instead they keep
repeating the same line over and over
again I think alireza should seriously
contemplate a switch in the next game
but we'll get to that right now we have
another Bishop E6 Bishop D6 Carlsbad
yeah and I thought that this uh
initially went uh fairly well for
alireza the last time that they played
it not to the point where andrekin needs
to sort of like rethink things and
change the opening but I didn't think
that on Drake and got that much last
time
no I agree completely I think it's such
a solid setup for Black
and we have the same exact structure
with that trade on G3
yeah Queen on B8 seems a little silly
and distant but the queen will join uh
D6 and I'm still waiting for to move A5
at some point what let's shake things up
with long Castle he says smooth
transition there and black needs to
transition from positional play on in
the center to Rapid Fire Pawn storm on
the queen side the big decision for
black is whether you go B5 or C5 alireza
he focuses on opening up as many files
as possible opens that C file that
Bishop on E6 really really good
defensive piece because it ensures that
the D5 Pawn doesn't become too much of a
liability
that's right yeah and Rook CA the move
the move C5 you'd almost never think of
when the king's a new one but it's
amazing as soon as long Castle goes is
like a gut reaction C5 he knows he needs
to open up the center the C file and if
he does nothing he's just gonna get
bowled over on the king side now what's
making Dimitri's mouthwater is the
prospect of the H file opening and the
only way to achieve that is to play G4
G5 to achieve that you need to
counteract the influence of the bishop
on E6 and the Knight on F6 and the way
to do that is probably to play Bishop F5
but even if you play Bishop F5 G4 can
still be met with Knight takes G4 so I
think logistically maybe Dimitri
overestimate or underestimated the
difficulty of opening up the H file and
alireza needs to use these Tempi and put
them to use by developing the queen side
play before white gets a chance to
switch to the other side of the board
yeah no that's uh that's great analysis
because it puts it in perspective what
each side is trying to do and what
they're calculating and evaluating right
now I mean the other way to get G4 is
also F3 but it's just such a convoluted
plan F3 also hangs the G3 Pawn so
it really feels like White's got an open
file but his job is much more difficult
like his attacking jobs more difficult
as a result if that pawn was on H3 I
might go G4 and immediately G5 suddenly
you know we have life
and funnily enough Knight Knight G5 is a
possible idea because H takes G5 runs
into Bishop H7 and White's got
essentially a draw in his pocket there
but Knight G5 itself does not create any
threats you can follow it up with Bishop
H7 check but as long as the Knight
remains on F6 and guards the H7 Square I
don't really see any mating patterns
there for white
no it's sort of like uh it's as good as
it looks and no further
exactly
so Rook C8 or C4 are those the two moves
that alireza has been investing over two
minutes now deciding the huge thing this
is a massive thing right now Monumental
he's two minutes down
let's hope that he's not planning
another you know howler of a move
um his last big think in this match did
yield one of those
yeah so something like G7 G5 would fit
the bill right pretty much
um but yeah I think C4 is the biggest
consideration because then the bishop
moves and you immediately play B5 you
get a lot of quick Tempe but by closing
it up you're sort of saying okay uh
we're both attacking each other it's a
free-for-all and I'm not sure whether he
wants a free-for-all game
this may seem beside the point but the
big benefit of going Rook C8 and
delaying C4
is that you do get the f8 square
potentially for the king so later on
whoa we'll get to the move in a second I
was gonna say later on black and Escape
through f8 should the H file open what
on Earth is this
what
I'm so perplexed it's such a strange
idea it allows 95 it locks in The Rook
so there's no Knight f8 and the King
doesn't have air
you could give me 10 attempts tonight I
would not Queen E8 would not be on my
radar which even if you told me it was a
queen move would you say Daniel that
sometimes when you start thinking for
more than like two minutes that you just
get in your own head and you feel the
need to produce something extraordinary
and you're like okay Queenie like she
probably spent the least amount of time
calculating Queen E8 and that's the
movie scene and I think that's also the
source of there's a famous quip by this
British GM John Nunn who you know said
one of those semi-controversial
statements that if you think for longer
than 15 minutes and he was referring to
classical chess then by definition
you're gonna make a mistake and there's
a grain of Truth to that of course it's
uh one of those General statements
that's meant to elicit emotion as we see
Knight G5 essentially I think a draw
offer
um and with the queen on E8 I do think
alireza actually has to take that Knight
but there's really something to that at
some point you know the time that you
spend starts working against your favor
yeah
yep no it's that's completely true and I
think it did happen here is are you
worried taking this night that you're
that you're in trouble
um because if this is a draw I think you
want it as as far Asia here
yeah I mean I guess your alternative is
to play Queen E7 but then you'll allow
Knight takes E6 and you have to weaken
your king side further and then G4
becomes more of an option and with a
Time situation I think alireza is just
double checking to make sure that after
a note pun intended after Bishop H7 King
h8 oh but he goes for it
right and man I feel like he's gonna
regret it Knight takes C6 I'm on and
then that Bishop from H7 can stick
itself on G6 and then white can put into
practice the plan that you outlined with
F3 and G4 which is now far from as
convoluted as it used to be
yeah that's a I think this is kind of
wrong decision I mean very scary to take
that Knight but he's low on time I think
he wanted that draw if it was indeed one
I'm surprised that we don't see Knight
takes Pawn takes Bishop there and E4
instead Knight to E2 and I mean if he
doesn't take this fight things are gonna
get bad and he should take this Knight
but he might just be afraid it might not
be the case that he's declining a draw
but maybe he's fearing ghosts after H
takes G5 it is very scary but good on
alireza he takes the second chance and
we will see a draw by Perpetual check
that Bishop can move literally anywhere
except G8 and maybe we should show for
newer players Amman that Bishop G8 is a
very standard pattern that would lead to
Checkmate after King takes straight
Queen H7 were the Knight not on F6
but obviously here whoopsy Daisy and
instead alireza uh escapes with a draw
so I believe that
we'll just see yeah and you could
literally pick any squares
um you know you you almost as white want
to say oh you know Rook H2 Rook H1 but
as soon as you take a moment with Rook
H2 the draw might disappear
oh yeah definitely black could have gone
G6 there in King G7 so he had to do it
urgently and another draw
but yeah Miss chance they're buying
Drake and he could have taken that
bishop and he was clearly better
I think that could have been a second
victory for him instead he insists on
the draw and he maintains his one point
lead in the match
he does and you know what as the uh as
the you know all-knowing power here of
assigning points I'm gonna assign you
half a point Dania because you did not
get it correct that we would be
transitioning to the Italian however we
do see an opening shift D4 a big
decision from Ali Reza he is avoiding
that opening the schliemann from
andrekin a much more drastic uh choice
so not drastic in his actual opening
Choice wow he's chosen a very exotic
opening the Catalan yeah what an unwise
irresponsible decision but in all
seriousness I like this I like this a
lot more than stubbornly going into the
same line over and over again selfishly
this also gives us different types of
positions to talk about as commentators
uh so it's fun from that perspective as
well
yep we're mixing it up here a little bit
um the one thing about this line with
Bishop B4 I mean naturally I look at
these positions and I always feel like
oh this is kind of a nice achievement
for white because you look at the pawn
structure and especially that Bishop on
C8 my gut reaction is tough this is
terrible for black but it's tough for
white to make progress because E4 you
need to spend some time achieving black
can also take on C4 and go E5 and
finally if you ever take here Black's
taking back with the epon and we're
actually transitioning back to the same
opening that we've seen uh farooja
playing this match this is what some
Russian GMS refer to as bunker chess
where you you build yourself a little
cave everything is defended 600 times
like look at that D5 Pawn there's like a
pawn chain extending from the King side
to the center to the queen side and your
plan isn't really to do anything you
would want in an ideal world to find
suitable living arrangements for that
Bishop on C8 but the moment you play a
move like B6 you're allowing white to
play C takes D5 and then you have to
recapture with the c pawn and then
whitesnite from A3 will jump into B5 so
I will be honestly what I can't play
these types of positions with black I
can't sit there and play rookie 8 and H6
and King h18 King G8 but that's why
Dimitri and Drake is over 2 700 feet a
and I'm not
the thing is it's such a skill in chess
to be able to do nothing well oh yeah to
be able to make moves that seemingly do
nothing uh but actually maintain the
balance is an incredible skill and
almost the requirement to play this
opening age six was the top engine move
the second engine move was rookie a to
f8 and then the next move of the line
was Rook f8 to d8 right that tells you
all you need to know if the engine can't
find anything productive to do then that
tells you it's bunker chest time
yeah no that's such a great such a great
word for what we're watching here
because yeah you want to maybe take but
the knights on A3 ready to to take back
and then from White's perspective yeah
you might want to take but Black's not
forced to take with the c Pawn so
there's all these moves that you just
don't really want to do because you
don't want to help out your opponent and
it leads to like neither side wanting to
do anything
now LaRosa trying to kind of tighten the
screws a little bit you know
paint some of the splotchy
uh kind of paint marks on the wall this
is how you approach these types of
positions you can't do anything big you
have to make a series of tiny little
Home Improvements until eventually an
opportunity manifests itself let's say
to open up the center but how is Dimitri
going to continue doing nothing will he
play Queen D6 will the knight from D7
ultimately try to access the B4 Square
which is a potentially juicy Outpost but
it's a very treacherous path to getting
there and the moment you put your knight
on A6 obviously the A5 Pawn will fall so
that might be practically impossible
right
um you know top moves here in the
position for black include Rook d8
Knight d8 Rook at five it's all standard
ideas
there we go we got some action wow I
feel like I just saw somebody hang a
piece or something well you might see
somebody hang up on because if Dimitri
plays E5 which he just did Knight takes
A5 does secure that pawn ah he wants he
takes D4 and 94 he wants to go after
white light squared bishop and force Ali
Reza to give it away I actually really
like that from a practical point of view
yep knowing the moment
um takes takes 94 and the queen doesn't
really have any squares that uh she can
go to to still defend the Knight on E5
but Knight B6 interesting
um okay it's almost a pure sacrifice
he gets the D5 Square what does he get
an insurance for the body he has
temporarily better piece coordination
while the Knight on A5 is still
awkwardly placed and of course still
Knight E4 is looming in the air which is
why I would play Knight D3 here in order
to prevent Knight E4 then white will
have Bishop takes E4 and rookie one
anytime your Rooks are not coordinated
you always pay the price for it
tactically
Knight D3 looks super super strong
because when the Knight reaches C5 it
finally defends the a pawn and then this
Knight can move because right now you
almost want to you know pickpocket and
just get out safely but the a pawn is
hanging so you can't quite do it
absolutely
and alireza once again he has been
taking some long thinks in the early
going of this match this will be the
last game before the break before our
midpoint break in the five minute
segment he decides instead to trade the
knights but look at Dimitri diving into
E2 offering an exchange of Queens
should white trainer do you try to trade
on your own terms what if you trade and
go Rook C2 like is
is there some like Rook takes A4 oh my
God
oh my God
wow and double question mark is harsh
but guys rookie for on Drake and what a
what a game and what a move of course
give it a brilliancy
oh it's so beautiful when both Rooks are
hanging like this and we should show
that the point is Rook takes A4 white
gets Chuck mated and the pod on H6 is
the hero in all of these complications
because after Bishop F1 Bishop H3 white
would have Rook a a check but now
there's just King H7 and Rook takes F1
Checkmate can be staved off but not
prevented
because we know that he's not gonna let
us see it no he's not
yeah rip tasty too
Rogue D1 wins another Pawn
it's amazing right Rook takes A4
brilliancy and it's brilliantly
equalized the material you know it's
like that's the type of brilliancy that
you find at this level
and Rook takes a for just the moment
that you thought you can breathe the
Queens are off the board I can slowly
consolidate my extra Pawn you let your
guard down and this happens at every
level right we see this happen at the
club player level but we also see this
happen at the most elite of levels it's
just basic psychology
that was a really really cool move and
especially because the way on draken was
playing that game as you said bunker
chess who knew that the bunker was so
tactical yeah bunker explodes
rugby 4K clear extra Pawn I mean I'm
draken
you have to be thinking if you're
Dimitri on draken that this is your game
to win and really put a statement on
this match so far because if I'm not
mistaken Ali Reza has not won a game yet
no and this you're absolutely right I'm
on you know it's you really really needs
to win this game uh to put that Mark as
you said on the first half of the five
minute portion because if he gives up
another half point then that will do
wonders for Ali Reza's confidence Ali
Reza will start feeling like he can
really hold anything
um even if he makes a couple of big
blunders in the game so can Dimitri
harness his excellent endgame technique
and his time advantage and convert this
to a victory big big moment here in this
game
and it is let me just get a check that's
right move 25 and black has completed
development yeah Bishop finally comes
out and what a bishop it is on E6
beautiful Square
what do you think of Bishop C4 like uh
what do you think of going forcing that
end game
I think that black can probably achieve
that whenever he wants to like almost on
demand so I would keep the Rooks for now
just because you've got your Rook
trained at that B2 pawn and if you find
that you're having a hard time making
progress then you can try to engineer a
rook trade I would go Bishop F5 here and
try to go G5 there remember G5 old
friend from our previous game that's
right I still remember that and wow the
bishop on C4 is actually even it feels
like it is even better for the movie C5
now it's a serious threat
if I was playing a classical game
against either of these players and I
had white I would actually consider
resigning this is not because this is
dead lost but because it's so nasty to
try to defend these types of end games
yeah you know you're like the best case
scenario might be the hardest draw of
your entire life exactly
yeah like a 90 move you know grinding
down upon until the last move Cliff
clinging
exactly
here's a great Square we haven't had
many of those for the white pieces this
game so I figured I'd mention it 93
that's right it's gone yeah what Square
I need one okay so a lot of rerouting I
feel like black has uh actually done a
really good job don't forget the time
situation andrekin is just tightening
the screws right now you mentioned the
B2 Pawn White's pieces are fully on the
defensive this would be a tough position
if the material was equal
it may seem like Ollie Rose is just kind
of doing cartwheels in the swamp but
he's actually improving his position his
Knight is on F3 now his Rook is on an
open file
this actually has been a really
impressive defensive effort for resin I
think Dimitri has to go after that B2
Pawn that Knight on T5 looks pretty but
I think it would be much better served
on C4 or on A4 but things could get
tactical there I mean alireza could jump
into E5 with his Knight and he could try
to engineer some counter play against
Black's King so instead Dimitri where is
he bringing his Knight probably to E6 as
kind of a Transit point
yeah Knight there King will go back
the E3 Square you know that feels pretty
comfy
ooh trying to induce while the rest is
definitely not going G4
anytime this game yeah I was gonna say
not anytime soon anytime ever yeah no
you will not give up the F4 Square
white just treading water he's down to
three seconds
all right I don't know about this 95
check is a threat
and remember there's yeah you can almost
just Chase the king forever 95. whoa
whoa whoa whoa
God Dimitri is giving away so much
counter play yeah he wanted to take this
Pawn with Chuck he's got two connected
pass pawns but but then what
rugby five maybe should be tried but
alireza he doesn't need to do anything
that Knight on E5 is safely defended and
The Rook on F5 has plenty of squares
along the fifth rank should the Knight
attack it but here comes black b-pawn
can you stop it maybe no C5 though oh
that's a dagger
B3 really is
push-up what what's white doing
Gotta Get The Rook back to G1 to stop
the pawn
there might be like a knight D3 move I
almost want to
I think Knight D3 and yeah C3 Rook C2
wow and C5 C4 yeah Justin Rook C2 look
at this technique with four seconds
Dimitri finding every move C5 with a
check C4 with a check B2 with a win wow
the way he just took that from seemingly
nothing almost looked like he he ruined
his Advantage but he did just started
pushing he did but alireza delayed for
one extra move and that technique with
the last five seconds was absolutely
Exquisite those were only moves of mine
they were truthfully they they were in
alireza at some point you can't do a
better defensive job than that right
like to make your opponent have one path
to Victory he was already in a tough
spot I feel like Ali Reza defended well
but you're just up against a better
conversion
oh it just was incredible and it allows
Dimitri and draken to jump to a
two-point lead in the first portion of
the five plus one segment of the speed
Chess Championship presented by coinbase
only Raza farusha is the favorite no
question about that but he will have a
lot of work to do he blundered made in
one and now he's succumbed to some
excellent defensive technique folks we
will go on our first break of the day
when we come back we will have the
second portion of the five plus one
segment here at the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase
[Music]
thanks
foreign
excellent welcome everyone we are here
with Judith Polgar the legendary chess
player one of the greatest chess players
of all time
and I went my next move I said no I'm
not moving my queen I'm not moving my
Bishop but actually I'm going to give
Checkmate or winning great material and
I went 93.
[Music]
it works only that way if your attacker
you sacrifice something go all the way
until the end don't chicken out in the
meantime at some point because many
times there is a point there is no way
back it's only forward
[Music]
[Applause]
how is it to play with kasparo when you
saw him personally
he really had this incredible energy
shoot it thank you so much for being
with us and I hope you hope you're ready
to to dive into the past with us oh
absolutely I'm very happy to share with
you some of my most memorable games
foreign
Andrea and I'm Alex and we've been
playing competitive chess since we were
six years old
[Music]
started by focusing on classical chess
but later we fell in love with playing
Blitz and bullet online
[Music]
this has been around for more than 1 000
years but that doesn't mean that we
can't modernize it Financial systems
have been around for even longer sounds
like it's time for an update and
coinbase is doing just that
re-envisioning an entirely new Financial
system that is decentralized and fully
transparent also huge thank you to
coinbase for sponsoring competitive
chess and making events like the SCC
happen go to coinbase.com update the
system to learn more
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
draken the veteran Grandmaster sipping
his coffee and he has earned it because
he leads his SCC match against alireza
farouza by two points Dimitri and draken
had a tough time getting here he had to
do it the hard way the old school way
through the qualifier number two run as
we see some of the players that he
defeated on route to qualifying for the
SEC he defeated serrana Eduardo rizaga
Bonelli and Alexander shimanov ichopum
would themselves make up a very
difficult SCC opponent Iman really
impressive stuff for Dimitri and he has
not stopped there he hasn't missed a
beat in this match so far
yeah I was actually looking at it did he
lose this
um I wasn't sure if he won that match or
not uh if that was his path but uh oh
definitely
definitely impressive I think that was
like he he won lost and then had to win
to qualify which is like honestly even
more impressive when you when you think
about it yeah I apologize I misread that
uh that that graphic he did lose to
Serana but then he won on demand that's
actually what I'm trying to say I was
just testing to make sure that you
remember that yeah you games menu
I always one step ahead I'm on don't you
know well I'm draken has been one step
ahead of alireza who's missed made in
one and has just gotten soundly
outplayed in a beautiful positional game
bye Dimitri that last game of the black
pieces really well done
yeah and uh it's been a little bit of
both uh like there are multiple ways
that things can go wrong in a match or
in a game but it feels like a little bit
everything has happened he's missed big
time you know moves and blunders in the
maiden one but he's also as you said
just got sort of routinely and slowly
outplayed in a pawn up position by
andrekin so both trust me do not feel
good but I think he's going to be uh a
little bit discouraged here so I wonder
how he's gonna bounce back after the
break
well as the underdog you can't rest on
your laurels right you have a two-point
lead but you need to milk the segments
that are going in your favor so this
second 45 minutes of the five plus one I
really think Dimitri needs to make a
push to try to extend this lead to
something like four points because we
know that as the clock time uh shrinks
uh as the segments decrease alireza
becomes more of a favorite
and that sounds like honestly a great
name for the you know novel when we
finally release it
as the clock time shrinks as the very
nice it's very poetic yeah very poetic
uh well said Dania and hey a familiar
face look at this opening it's making an
appearance once again I have to say this
this has been what I would call a bright
spot for alireza I've always liked his
positions here but just some strange
decisions maybe later on in the games
remember he had that Queen E8 move that
it just caught us off guard but I've
liked his openings here
and what a provocative
slight little change by Reza his Bishop
does end up on E6 but it jumped to G4
first provoking 95 and I think his point
is that that Knight on E5 is not as well
supported as it may appear of course the
typical move is F2 F4 but that move is
associated with a very steep positional
price tag right you weaken the E4 Square
so instead Dimitri focusing on
completing his minor piece development
and you pointed out C5 which is a very
typical way to undermine that Knight on
E5
and uh Dania I mean what did we think of
the move H4 uh I'll go up and say it I
mean look H4 gets played against Me I'm
Scared that's just I always am it is a
scary move to face but I think at the
higher level you sort of realize that
you're not actually threatening anything
and instead he's gotten like the
opposite route he's like I don't like
this bishop so much that I'm just gonna
give it away but the reason he gave it
away is to take the sting out of the
weakness of the E4 Square now black
doesn't have a piece to put on it and so
F4 is much more positionally Justified
but I think now is a good time to
consider playing C5 to try to Chip Away
uh at White's dominance over the center
yeah um I think that C5 Knight B5 is a
really it's a really weird feeling for
black because the C Pawn hangs you know
take this here doesn't feel good either
and Knight C7 is coming
I did miss it I have to confess
apparently black can make that line work
by sacking The Rook in the corner and I
can guarantee you this is exactly what
alirez is calculating if he decides
against it he's likely to play A6 to
cover the B5 score but that also might
be a little bit too slow because maybe
after A6 white can go Knight A4 or
something and really bind up those dark
squares on the queen side and make it
difficult for black to ever play C5
yeah good point it's it's sometimes Now
or Never when it comes to the move C5
you don't take your chance to play it it
might not be there later and okay Queen
H4 did not expect
um he obviously wanted to play the move
Queen E7 and thought well I'll throw in
Queen H4 to force the move G3 which
Danny it actually has some logic to it
when White Castles you can't play Rook
F3 and lift The Rook anymore suddenly
your light squares are a little bit
weaker so I I kind of like the idea if
you're going to play Queen E7 to throw
in the check first
yeah I mean now the elephant in the room
or should I say the horse in the room is
that Knight on E5 and what black is
going to do with it I'll tell you what
black will not do with it black will not
play F6
um actually not even because of Knight
G6 but because of Bishop H7 check and
then Knight G6 winning the queen right
so black and trade it black and just
play Bishop takes E5 and maybe follow
that up with F6 or black and go Knight
D7 and try to kind of work around that
night but man I don't think I would I
think I'd pull the trigger on Bishop
takes C5
yeah it's a tough move to play I think
the main thing is after d takes E5 to
know that your Bishop on E6 has options
Bishop H3 and you can consider F6 there
to undermine the the pawn so you're not
just getting like completely stormed
totally and that Bishop on H3 nicely
situated
defensively as well because it's
covering the F1 square and preventing
light from doubling which could be
meaningful if in fact the trade on E5
occurs not only Reza taking the other
route right for now he develops his
Knight that doesn't mean he won't play
Bishop takes E5 but he's just kind of
waiting for white to put his cards on
the table my guess is Dimitri Miko
Queenie too and try to shuttle that
Queen over to H5
and remember if if you're thinking about
Bishop F5 here it's a it's a blunder
um now you might think that it's a
decent move but to not include Bishop H7
check is Criminal and as you can see
here question mark applied welcome to my
Ted Talk on why you should always play
Bishop H7 check and then do it it is the
grand masterly approach
and you're absolutely right to be honest
I thought you would take that in a
different direction when you said Bishop
F5 is a blunder I thought you would say
it's a positional blunder uh because you
don't want to give up uh eternally
control over all of the light squares
and I would agree with that as well I
think black and now play Bishop takes C5
and F6 I've been saying that for the
past five years I feel like every time
I'm like I can take on E5 and follow up
with F6 but this is especially annoying
for white now because that Queen on F5
is actually going to end up super
misplaced it's going to end up under the
watchful eye of black stroke instead I
think alireza wants to go Bishop B4 and
ultimately establish a knight on e4
which also looks pretty good to be
honest
yeah it really does
um I would say that and this probably
includes myself as well it's
it's really an uncomfortable feeling to
have that Knight on E5 anchored by the
pawns and no deep down that you cannot
evict it with F6 for the most part so I
think it's a real skill to be able to
handle that night and work around it and
we're seeing Ali Reza with numerous ways
that he's shown that that he knows how
to do that so kind of impressive to
watch as he plays Queen E6 and I'm
wondering if that was necessary
I don't know about that now
it feels like
things were a little scary there for
Dimitri for a couple of moves now it
feels just like largely an equal end
game white of course can resort to the
classic idea in any Queen's Gambit
decline which is the minority attack
with b2b4 and eventually B5 but in an
end game that could backfire because
white also has to keep a very watchful
eye on the E4 Square which means that
it's a good idea to keep the Knight on
C3 anchored by the B2 Pawn just to make
sure that that whole construction is
stable
right yeah if you rush with B5 all of a
sudden you might be helping you know
black create a pass Pawn helping them
use the open C file uh E4 if white could
achieve it would not not be a bad idea
I'm expecting slower moves King G2 uh
maybe Rook E2 and E4
Queen E6 was a bad move by alireza it
just you can just feel it
yeah
yep andreakin was very very happy there
especially because you were pointing out
some much nicer options as well like
capturing on E5 and F6 shall I go ahead
and say it for once
please do I think I've reached my Bishop
takes E5 F6 allotment for the day
before okay very very committal I mean
you actually brought up a really good
point which I agree with that it feels
like
you don't want to lose that anchor on
the C3 Knight
um but it is very difficult to achieve
C5 white can always play Knight A4 and
the Rooks are actually ready to double
based on the fact that you know they're
on like the first and second rank
yeah I think the point of B4 in this
particular instance is actually not to
play B5 at all but rather as you said to
establish this bind on the dark squares
and prevent black from ever really going
C5 so Dimitri is going to keep his Pawn
on B4 for the foreseeable future now
maybe he can push the other one he can
play A4 and A5 but right now he's trying
to play flexibly he's amassing his
pieces on the queen side everything is
super compact black has no obvious plan
and alireza he says wait what was that
about an obvious plan
yeah
G G5 is interesting because I'm actually
wondering after Pawn takes on F4 as
white I might just play uh the E Pawn
takes back on F4 yes an isolated Pawn on
D4 but it looks a little difficult to
attack and I also open up you know the
floodgates the firing lines uh towards
that E6 Pawn
yeah I like that plan a lot
and Retreat is regretting moving all of
his Pieces away from the King side Well
for now his Pawn structure essentially
is self-sufficient I don't think he
needs to overreact and play something
like Rook G2
but he's got to decide how he will
recapture on F4 in the event of G takes
F4 and all of that is going to take him
some time
yep
Knight G4 King F3 and you actually see
the power of Rook on C2 yep
and comes up to F3 will alireza lock up
the king side with G4 and follow up with
maybe H5 and H4 I like that idea because
the Rooks can get to the H file really
quickly right Rook H7 and Rook h8 only
takes you two moves yeah and blacks
Brooks let's not forget are the same as
White's Rooks they're poised to double
up really really quickly I would say
King E2 Knight F2 and maybe E4 comes to
mind
yeah this whole journey of the white
king to F3 might have been almost
counterproductive
right
yeah exactly this uh this looks quick
for black and at the very least whether
or not you could argue whether the plan
is like good bad whatever it's a plan
and Ali Raza has got some quick moves in
as a result both guys at 30 seconds this
might be Ali residence chance I think
this is trending in his favor right now
completely and H4 is a very heads up
decision I think by Dimitri trying to
keep the king side closed
and and posing black with another
difficult dilemma with only 20 seconds
left on passant will be met with Rook H1
white will recapture H3 and protect the
G3 Pawn simultaneously
yeah my my feeling was maybe black
wanted just Knight G8 knight uh to F5
but okay we'll see how this plays out
king F3 perhaps it'd be 90 oh no 94
drops the H Pawn see that's the problem
H5 is a long-term weakness Black's
Knight is tied down and maybe you're
playing Knight F2 and E4 suddenly it
feels like white can take over the
initiative again
yeah this position bothers me a little
bit Rook H2 Knight F2 I just feel like
the bishop Black's Bishop is not
participating
looks like Dimitri is still in kind of
solid bunker mode but still Knight F2
and E4 very tempting plan five seconds
bunker mode with five seconds we'll see
exactly how it works out the position
opening up alirez is striking with C5
this is where Reza is so good these time
scrambles with the increment is he
taking over the initiative
one second oh he blundered d e oh oh my
goodness 19 H5 is everything oh things
are collapsing but alireza still has
that c Pawn which you can try to convert
in concrete counter Play It's Not Over
G3
what a mistake completely hanging
and I don't even know who's favored now
and alireza trying to set up a mating
net but the King has G4 and the King can
zigzag its way out of the checks and it
does but it's still double edged Knight
D4
yeah
and made threat
oh my goodness but Rook C6 such a heads
up move King G6 oh he gave up his Knight
but you can't take it
wow this isn't this is very very tricky
stuff oh no but Dimitri's gonna lose
Rook C4
Dimitri's gonna lose this
ooh that is a very very good move to
keep the Rooks on what just happened I'm
still I'm actually I don't I was seeing
the moves but I wasn't like
understanding who was winning until the
very end and then I saw for arugia one
and I'm like okay I think I knew who was
winning
wow guys that was a really big moment
for farugia in this match because it
actually did look like he was making a
comeback but then it just became time
scramble mode and it's really hard to
just make judgments on like oh yeah but
he was just winning here he just had to
make that one move I'm sure they both
had moments where they were completely
winning that's just the nature of a Time
scramble ultimately it's whoever keeps
their nerve and comes out on top that's
where furuja excels yeah we could bring
up an announcement and start pointing
out okay
this is where Dimitri actually blundered
but all of that is totally pointless the
fact of the matter is alireza is a
better time Scrambler and it's not a
coincidence that he wins most of these
crazy back and forth scrambles it's just
what he does he always seems to find the
right move at the right time and uh this
doesn't bode very well for Dimitri's
chances in the shorter time controls and
a very very difficult pill to swallow
there I'm on because this could have
been a three-point lead if demat had
converted his Advantage at the end
yep absolutely or you know it could have
just been he could have just maintained
the balance instead Ali Reza is
breathing some life into his position
and I will just back up just slightly
just because yeah yeah please do
something just like flew by us all here
especially me and it was like wait a
minute what did I just look at Bishop
takes C6 and it's like okay it takes 95
F4 uh whites may be snatching that pawn
black responded uh on draken with the
move E4 and both players just in stride
Bishop takes D5 yeah yeah I've seen this
before and here we are
um after Bishop F5 so must be deep in
the bunker The Trenches of theory yeah
we must be I mean
I honestly have no intuition about the
proper evaluation of this position you
could make a case that white is better
he's up upon the Rook can come out to D1
but you could also make the case that
white is in a lot of danger here because
H6 is a serious positional threat it
tosses the Knight back to H3 Bishop
takes H3 ruins the pawn structure The
Rook from f8 can jump into F3 so all the
rest of making the decision to repeat
this yet again
but is it backfiring yet again let's see
how he handles this situation win H5
Maybe
I do feel that andrekin
um fully comprehends how his pieces
should be placed which seems more
important than specifically like when
this move happens you have to do that
it's like more just a general
understanding here Queen C6 was actually
the only Square to maintain any
semblance of
I guess
equality I don't even want to say that
probably we're far from equal but you
know playability maybe I think the the
phrase that lazy commentators like to
use is dynamic equality
and the way it was explained to me is
like a situation where the engine says
equal but when you look at the position
you have no idea what's going on but if
Bishop takes H3 happens then the
material on the board starts to become
more balanced and there we go Rook F3
the typical follow-up
and now the smoke is starting to clear
it I still don't know who's playing for
the advantage here though
yeah because there's one thing that is
true is although black wins this Pawn
back I think if you just go ahead and
take it you're not you're not doing as
well as you could all of a sudden there
would appear Queen G4 and rope D7 rope
G1 Bishop H6 Bishop D4 and you're like
wait a minute hang on just a second I
thought I was the one exposing your king
and winning my material back you're
absolutely right Rook F3 is such an easy
move to misinterpret you might look at
it and say oh you're going after the H
Pawn no you're just sticking The Rook on
an outpost and you're actually it's
almost a defensive move you're
preventing Queen G4 as you're showing
and of course you're potentially
preparing to double on the f file but if
I'm Dimitri I'm seriously thinking about
investing a Tempo on improving my king
safety and tucking the king away on H7
at some point you might have to do that
if and when alireza plays Rook G1
yep yeah King H7 and for the most part
black trying to operate on the light
squares here just safety measures with
dark Square Bishops on the board
um I think King H7 he will do here but
what if alireza starts doubling on the G
file
rope G3 or not even could just go Richie
too he starts with C3 just taking away
The Bishop's influence on the long
diagonal now it's just kind of biting on
granite I think Dimitri should
reposition it to E5 at least and then
Rook takes H3 actually does become more
of a possibility because H2 will be
under Fire as a result and I think it's
a perfect time for Reza to play Rook G2
and reinforce that H2 Pawn which is
exactly what he does
yep Rook takes Queen G4 as always and
yeah the simple idea of Rook A1 to G1
and then white will be so solid and you
can kind of think about repositioning
this queen
for sure and that Queen can kind of
sneak its way around all of the
obstacles it can move laterally to C2 at
some point and hit the E4 pawn queen E6
great move by Dimitri keeping his Rook
on F3 at all costs and instead using his
queen as the primary attacker
the most important Pawn though in the
position is the one on e4 so white could
win this e-pawn nearly at any cost I
would say that's totally worth it I'm
afraid to ask what happens after Queen
takes H3
I mean it's not in the computer's list
of top moves so I guess Queen C4 is
problematic I don't know we'd be fine
yeah exactly I think it it has to do
with again that e-pawn it's like you go
too far away and the combined threats of
like maybe bishop C5 to hit the rook and
E4 Pawn loose
he timed Rook takes H3 perfectly did
Dimitri that's why he put his Queen on
E6 now Queen G4 isn't just an equal end
game you actually blundered made in one
on H2
yeah a huge mistake there but
surprisingly uncomfortable or white
because not a single piece feels like it
can move right now I would play Bishop
D4 and I would try to disarm the
pressure on A2 so that not only can you
move move a muscle but eventually you
might get a rook to G7 although that
check is less scary than it appears
because the king can drop back to h8 and
it's not the end of the world
so you're saying Daniel that you're not
interested in one of the top moves in
the position
because it was almost surprising
I'm shocked my my own my own brain
puzzles me sometimes
this looks like a safety first kind of
move
um I have to give credit to ondrakin
because I I was viewing White's position
as just easier to play but so accurate
with the timing of King H7 Bishop E5 and
then as you said Rook H3 in the right
moment I feel like andrekin has played
this uh position quite well yeah that
last game was a bitter pill to swallow
but he has been playing great so far in
this match there's the quality of moves
by by Dima has been very consistent and
very high you know the only potential
point of weakness is his time scrambling
ability which is why he has to try to
avoid those all-out scrambles but it's
really hard to do because of how good
alireza is at uh posing constant sets of
problems apparently there's a crazy move
here that gives white a big Advantage I
don't even want to say it I feel like
I'm profaning you know my job as a
commentator by even speaking this move
into existence it's F4
F4
and white is winning
the most ridiculous thing I've ever
heard exactly okay D5 makes more sense
trying to get the G4 Square for his
Queen
jeez yeah how could he miss that I mean
I don't know it's ridiculous honestly
I think he should be kicked out of the
match
well I'll go ahead and and put at least
something on the board uh just a
variation here so Queen takes place five
uh Queen uh G4 Queen F5 and the rather
pleasurable Queen G7 and
of course gets to see a Checkmate queen
queen G8 Checkmate deserved attention uh
but I would definitely play Queen G7 in
a bullet game
first you know uh Queen G8 is for those
that do not enjoy the beauty of the game
Daniel
for sure and that would be me
squarely all good players
yeah well Dimitri doesn't eat of the
tree of knowledge he keeps his control
over the G4 square and it still feels
like white is on the uncomfortable side
here
yeah
yeah Queen F5 is uh it's almost like you
know nice attempt there Junior you know
D5 it's not gonna work it's not gonna
work
switches his attention to the epon which
he wants to capture with the queen trade
I think Dimitri should calmly defend it
with Rook H4 if he wants a draw you can
probably go Rook D3 or even Queen
no Queen 65 now still doesn't work for
exactly the same reason that's right and
then now you have to go to G8 because I
have unfortunately you have to settle
for Maiden one there
life is tough
I'm enjoying the dynamic equality we
have here
yeah nothing's changed in the last 15
moves it's been
this very very tense situation where
both sides are trying to keep a lot of
squares under their supervision
I think it's time for a queen trade I
think we've had enough of this short
middle game nonsense how was my Dynamic
equality usage I'm I'm still new to the
term you've got you know some room to
grow but it's a pretty good start
I'll work on it Queen F3 makes sense I I
mean both sides just have their
weaknesses it looks like the epon and
the d-pawn are first to go
um Queen F3 were really trending towards
like actual equality just pure because I
think we're about to get into a rook end
game where
although they'll be like imbalances
three on two on the queen side Rook end
games even sometimes down a pawn are
just a draw and I don't expect this to
have much life in it although Rogue D7 I
actually thought for that reason maybe F
take C3
as weird as it would seem might have
been more accurate because now there's
this move C6 and white suddenly has a
back rank weakness and Dimitri finds it
wow and Ali Razzle will have to part
ways with his deep on he'll have to play
D6 to at least keep the E4 upon weak
but practically with three seconds can
he hold this together
yeah because now you want to coordinate
like Rook F4 Rook D2 perhaps
got C6 Dimitri has been finding all
sorts of these unexpected tactics in the
end game amazing you see this Rook is
kind of like I'm attacking you now you
now you now you
what the C Pawn hasn't taken a turn yet
being attacked I think it will after B5
there we go it felt left though Rook
takes C6 he's got the Perpetual of The
Rook C7 and Rook C8 and I think he's
gonna hold it
yeah
there we go
looks like the end here
amazing I had to just end in a draw a
dynamic equality it just fizzled out
ultimately led to static equality and
there was a brief scare there but
alireza kept his composure after C6 and
I don't think that you know maybe there
was a brief incident where Dimitri had
winning chances but you can't really
blame him for
giving up the draw there it was a very
well played game by both sides
that's right that's right
um going back to this is
Ali Reza I think that on Drake and I was
gonna say
he's probably gonna switch it up even
though the game ended up being kind of
okay for him I don't think he really
enjoyed
um how how it went after F4 there uh Ali
Reza just kind of didn't have to play
Queen E6 previously yeah completely
different type of position alireza
quickly strikes with C5 and Knight C6
this is the the classical plan which
leads to a nitrate and a hanging Pawn
structure
always fun I mean these these positions
are very very rich and uh there's
something sometimes ideas of Bishop H2
H2 So like
um maybe taking let's show it five yeah
yeah let's show it this is a very
instructive idea because Bishop H2 King
H2 Knight G4 everybody thinks that white
wins with King G3 uh but black is G5
this is the basic uh calculation but
yeah as you pointed out king G3 like
okay uh hitting hitting the queen
defending the bishop but yeah G5 what a
shot
black unfurls a massive attack against
white skin and that is why Dimitri
chooses not to engage with any of this
just shifts his skin to H1 Bishop takes
H2 now runs into Bishop takes F6 that's
the idea
King H1 is such a funny funny looking
move
um yeah but it makes me really look at
uh Black's position and say okay well if
you manage to get this and white
couldn't play Pawn takes I feel like
you're happy here as as black would you
go C4 or do you think the trade on D4 is
more
congruent with Black's ideas
I would take personally just because I I
feel like if you go C4 that the
long-term Outlook is B3 happening and me
taking and I'm pretty much getting
almost the same structure as Pawn takes
here so I would probably take what about
you
yeah I'm leaning towards C takes D4 also
because after e takes D4 whites got the
isolated Pawn on D4 which could be
attacked later on by moves like Queen B6
of course the pin along the h4da
diagonal is annoying so as passive as it
appears I would be contemplating Bishop
E7 at some point just to free yourself
up in the center
right but you probably wouldn't want to
do it before dealing with this Pawn so
that's why I think we're gonna get some
sort of resolution to the D4 C5 you know
long-term tension great call so takes
takes and C5
a very interesting follow-up decision it
always is satisfying when you can play
the same move with two different Pawns
in the span of like three overall moves
yeah this is like uh Bug House when
someone's like you know okay and now I
need to find E3 yeah take take Pawn on
C5 Pawn at E3 and you just go forever
yeah you keep creating a hole and then
putting a putting a pot in it and you
you seem to have an unlimited supply of
Pawns now the the situation becomes very
Tactical
pushes this Pawn to C4 you can't really
take on D6 here I think because if C
takes D3
it looks unadvertising you can do Bishop
H7 and maybe cans should be replaced by
must should yeah compelled to that is
replaced by does
there you go yeah this is all going to
be pretty much for us then the Knight of
course will uh we'll grab this bishop
and
looks good the bishop on H7 is safe but
nonetheless a little bit too adventurous
for on draken's taste he brings it back
to F5
feels like whites emerged from the
Tactical confrontation with a pretty
good position
yeah I agree I I think I jumped the gun
on Knight takes D6 because to be honest
if the Knight gets attacked I wouldn't
necessarily mind Knight C3
not at all exerting long-term pressure
on the D5 fund especially combined with
a potential trade of light script
Bishops that could cause major long-term
positional issues for Ali Reza who might
just have to defend passively here with
you know some some neutral move like
rookie 8 or maybe Rook B8 but your point
is well taken that night and jump back
to C3 at a moment's notice
yeah because the main thing is that at
some point black is probably going to go
Queen D7 and try to get white to capture
to undouble the pawns which seemingly
he's going to be able to force but if
ever these Bishops trade like this
without the pawn getting into E6 I think
even at the cost of a pawn uh White
would happily engage also relevant is
that in some cases white will play
Bishop take C6 and open up the G6 Square
for his Queen so Queen C2 to G6 could be
an interesting uh Avenue to explore as a
matter of fact even here Bishop takes E6
should be strongly considered because
the issue with Knight C3 is that you're
potentially giving up your B2 Pawn
um after Bishop takes F5 that line still
looks good for white but it has to be
carefully uh considered by by and draken
yeah I feel like Knight C3 I would be
interested in that line but the problem
for Knight C3 is that it's not forest
and black will just go maybe Queen D7 oh
yeah and and kind of force this to
happen and you know Queen G6 is always
held with Queen G7 so black actually
kind of improves there so apparently the
only way to keep the advantage here is
indeed just to trade both pairs of minor
pieces instead he does go for Knight C3
and great call I think we are going to
see Queen D7 and alireza is going to
force the Bishops off the board but on
his own terms
totally Queen D7 is a big time move you
you always have to pause and just make
sure Knight D5 yeah exactly no the King
was on G8 might be a different story but
it's uh Queen D7 needs to happen here
it's funny that the kings are on H1 and
h8 it's almost like they they redefine
the rules of castling it's now King E1
to H1
yep
ah man I guess I have to say I'm a
little surprised Queen D7 looked like
such an untangling but
can you really fault Ali Reza for a
clear double attack here
I mean I would be terrified of playing
this move because because again I'm a
broken record for the second straight
game right the last game was Bishop
takes C5 and F6 now it's this queen G6
idea but Queen G6 is fully met by Rook
B7 I think that's the the point and
queen takes H6 is just not scary because
of Rook H7 so instead Dimitri uses his
Rooks which I think is a much wiser
attacking strategy
yep and any kind of queen takes B2 it's
it's Black's position that crumbles even
though uh you know you get first blood
so to speak first
exactly exactly everything falls but
black gets a pin prick and white gets
but I think Queen G6 is even stronger
oh my gosh this might just be crushing
because we take C3 I'm on white takes on
H6 comes back to G6 and then lifts The
Rook up to E3 winning the game on the
spot
right
and that I mean you must be spoiled for
choice because I I was only thinking of
E6 and I was like oh that's good enough
it looks pretty good but this is even
better Queen G6 what a move polyureza
just completely forgetting I he
obviously saw that move I think he
forgot about rookie three
yeah and rookie three would win the
queen
is there I think he was he was so
reliant on Rook B7 so that's why you
kind of lose focus for a secular oh yeah
I got Rook B7 always handling
rugby one but that's that's the point
this is what he missed Rook B1 and Rook
takes E6 very easy move to make it's so
easy to tunnel vision the king side in
the center some of the hardest moves
involve whole board awareness but that's
why Dimitri is 27 30.
this is over
this is quite literally the end of the
game Queen takes C3 Rook takes B7 and
you don't even get to play you know oh
Bishop for Rook no no none of that it's
you're again mated it's literal
Checkmate or you lose your queen and
amazing whole board awareness by Dimitri
if you just look at his last couple of
moves they make such a big impression
because he's playing on all three sides
right he took on E6 and went rookie one
Center Queen G6 playing on the king side
and then Rook B1 using the queen set as
well using the whole board as his canvas
and winning a very important game
reinforcing and re-establishing the
two-point lead just fantastic chess
being played by on Dragon in the five
minute portion
long-term predictions coming true
there's the Italian Daniel
appearance yeah it took a while to to
you know remind himself that there was a
correct decision to me yeah I don't know
why you would ever follow this
particular commentator's advice but you
know alirez's mind works in mysterious
ways
selfishly you know as a fan and
commentator and spokesman for the chat I
will say uh but right now on draken
taking this uh this lead in the five
minute is going to give us a very
exciting match because you're gonna see
Back Against The Wall farrugia going to
have to turn this match around he can
certainly take a big stride right here
though Dania this will be the last game
before the break and really tone setting
uh depending on the result here yeah
tone setting is the perfect phrase to
use uh because man a world of difference
between a victory for Dimitri it would
give him his biggest lead of the match
versus a victory for alireza you know
for all of the the praise that we have
uh loaded Dimitri's play with you know
one point lead is nothing going into the
three minute portion so truly a pivotal
game
and will we see G5 and H5 by Dimitri is
that the reason why he's delaying chart
Castle
at delaying short Castle but also maybe
a tell
um when I see Queen E7 I feel like G5 is
right around the corner
I I cannot imagine him not playing Chief
like why on Earth otherwise would you go
to such length to avoid castling and put
the queen on E7
you're totally right I think we're
seeing G5 on the next move almost
regardless of what white plays yep
exactly the bishop dropping back is is
uh just good like caretaking you want to
get out of the D4 move Knight D2 I mean
G5 is screaming and maybe black can
start with Bishop G4 or even like Bishop
D7 but
I don't see a reason to delay G5 any
further the hard question is how you
follow up the move G5 because G5 Bishop
G3 is automatic first of all you have to
calculate H5 which leads to massive
complications white can play H4 y can
take G5
if you're not playing H5 then are you
playing Bishop G4 are you playing Bishop
E6 very very hard position to make heads
or tails of
that's right
these are these are such Rich positions
I mean Rook G8 as the next move he's
basically looking for H5 but in a safe
capacity now that pawn can't even be
taken
yeah H5 is now a serious tactical threat
and maybe it's time for Ali Rosa to
Counter-Strike in the center with D4
like you just don't have a lot of time
to waste if you're white there there is
a more positional treatment where you go
Bishop B3 and the Knight C4 but I just
don't know if White's got the time for
that
right I was thinking like in a similar
vein maybe the move A4
um because we kind of have this weird A5
move which may pose a few problems for
the pieces here we've got like a queen
A4 oh yeah in the woodwork
yeah that's a cool idea actually
Rook takes A5 and queen A4 check
obviously a byproduct of black leaving
his King in the center and alireza
recognizing that this is a this is a big
moment because D4 D4 is not a move that
you play lightly
no yeah exactly not at all especially
after Knight D2 you know disconnecting
the queen from that square I do think
that white needs to do something big
though which is why are you spending the
time like we don't have time for rookie
one you know like just basic uh
developing moves unless you have a clear
answer to hello H5 H4
there it is took him a while but he
ultimately settles on the most concrete
attempt at generating Central counter
play I really like that decision and I
think we should point out that he takes
D4
I think some people in the chat might
almost be afraid to ask the question
what exactly happens if black takes it
and I don't know the answer for certain
but I think E5 and Knight takes E5 is
devastating down the E file
can pull up an analysis for it and just
show what could happen at what won't
happen but what could if uh if they go
down this line I mean this is not what
Andre can signed up for he didn't play
G5 Rook G8 to have an open e-file yeah
and I think the reason why uh I love the
reaction from Perugia so much is that
it's textbook this is what you learn and
it's so nice to see it applied in an
actual game you're like oh the guy's
just out of nowhere go G5 Rook G8 What
is this nonsense play in the center open
up the center even at the cost of a pawn
so just like nice to see those things
that you learn actually working in
action especially at like the very
highest level so you know that chess
principles they do have a a role to play
in in one's thinking but Dimitri is not
following a lot of Chess principles he's
got a rook on G4 rather than a bishop
his Bishop is on D7 but look at the way
that alireza is maneuvering his pieces
and just massaging all of the weak
squares in Black's territory I pointed
out this idea in the context amount of
Bishop to B3 and Knight C4 instead he's
put the bishop on an even better square
and that knight from C4 threatens to
move back to E3 and then forward again
to D5 that is the big big drawback of
putting your queen on E7 and then
pushing G5 you've got this eternal pin
that might necessitate and exchange
sacrifice for black on H4 and then
things will get really exciting
yeah and I think this is uh you know an
exclamation mark awarded by force
because black didn't really have an
answer to Knight E3 so I think if it
does happen yeah you're right we will
see just some really wild variations but
I have to say those wild variations feel
like they're exactly what ondrakin's
hoping for so we may see a more tempered
approach from Ali resident here and I
just love the the universality with
which on draken is played he is I think
a positional player by by nature but
anytime that the position has gotten
sharp he has embraced the tactics and
he's found a lot of unexpected tactics
in critical moments okay this is a huge
moment Rook takes H4 can he gather the
wits to sack that exchange he can also
play Rook D to G8 and Sack The Exchange
that way that's even crazier
yeah this one's more natural because if
you evaluate pieces in the position
which is the worst one uh for white of
the two I would probably say the Knight
you want to leave that on the board the
bishop is just so annoying man I feel
like the chess.com move evaluator has
had a little bit of a little bit too
much coffee today like I don't know if
about two exclamation marks on road
takes H4 and it's essentially forced but
it is a nicer it's just like an undraken
fan in there
okay Queen takes E4
yep I don't I don't mind seeing a few
exclamation marks if these are the moves
we're getting because you know draken
deserves a lot of credit for being
willing to play this and you sort of
said it with you know the universal
style that he has he doesn't play like
this all the time but he can
oh he definitely can he is and it's easy
to forget that after Queen takes E4
black is technically up material you
know you've got two pawns for the
exchange so it's important not to blow
this exchange sack out of proportion
it's not like Dimitri has to show
something in the next two moves or he
loses right he's just playing chess and
the the Knight on F5 has lost the
support of the pawn it's now hanging and
rookie one runs into Queen F4 such a
nice hiding spot for the queen I think
we're gonna see just that unless Dmitry
plays Queen G4 and and tries to take the
Queens off
Queen D5 would be a blender of Epic
Proportions with vision m6 and 97 to
follow
okay
there it is
it's it's uh interesting you chose that
moment to point out black was up
material because that actually colors
the move Queen F4 you don't want to
trade Queens as black because you're
you're actually the one attacking here
there's there's no need you're totally
the one attacking after Rook G8 you can
see the impact the blacks Queen plays
when it sits on the queen side like that
you've got Queen takes H4 in some cases
when the Knight leaves F5 and now you're
supposed to play B take C6 to generate a
really nice little Luft Square for your
King on B7
absolutely
um Yep this looks really good and
remember if black gets the moment to
play Ponte C3 that Bishop is gonna be so
powerful Queen takes G3 ideas later on
okay he takes season sixes It's Tricky
you know you have to spend a moment to
justify because of you know every fiber
of your being wants to play Bishop takes
although the additional benefit of BC is
that you're keeping the attack on the F5
Knight so you're forcing white to put
his cards on the table and after Knight
takes D4 Rook G8 you make a very
important point that the knight from D4
is paralyzed because of the possibility
of Queen takes G3 which is just a
beautiful illustration of the power of
pins and Ali Raza just throwing all
caution to the wind going after Black's
Bishop on B6
yeah uh there is a nice see literally
hanging in the position as well but I
just don't understand how this move
Works in black and play Pawn takes C3
and after BC black takes on F5 and just
has the C5 Escape Square for for the
dark squid Bishop because white won't
have B4 anymore
that's that's correct
okay it takes immediately
ah Queen A4 was possible there
I don't like this approach by Dimitri
this is a lot more convoluted and again
we're gonna answer time scramble mode
and this is where alireza scores a lot
of points
right
yeah that being said after I was gonna
say Pawn takes you have the B4 square
but possibly you just underestimated
this queen takes C5 though how many
pawns does he have why didn't you play
Pawn takes it's ridiculous four pawns I
mean you have an opportunity there
Dimitri that would have been exceedingly
rare I think Eric Rosen would have been
proud of that alireza generating counter
play Queen A6 check is now a huge threat
yeah game winning queen bee oh we
defends the B1 Square okay okay you had
me going you had me going too one second
for alireza
this is alirez's like territory
okay but his pieces are all
discombobulated he's got no entry points
and Dimitri entering through E1 he's
gonna flag oh my goodness Queen F1 how
do you even have the most dexterity to
play that move how has he not flagged
yet and he's actually trying to hold it
but F2 Falls with check and now G1
drives the king out
and then Knight F3 and queen H2 and 95
and he's gonna at least win The Rook
but wait a second still only Rez is
still alive I think you can not for long
yeah
and queen B2 funny
A6 what a devilish little move but
Dimitri wasn't born yesterday
or was he
somebody check his birthday Queen E8 was
made in two queen E8 is made in two
eight is made in two
who's going for the win here I was gonna
say
trade and take G3
insane
alireza has a million lives but he's
finally running out of ideas Rook takes
G3 and unless black flags
what a move by the way okay now it
should be winning
black needs to just get a few like Rook
pre-moves you know like okay he's
stacking the time up Ollie Rez is gonna
lose unless he Forks The Rook I can't
believe that he's gotten this far what a
thriller of a final game here in the 5-1
portion this is insane and with a bishop
these types of end games with an extra
pawn and A4 can be a draw oh he's still
punching he's got you know one tentacle
left and now he finally resigns
what a final game of on
I I'm just blown away by that game
because Ali Reza looked dead to right he
was playing moves for like the spanned
the length of the chessboard with
literally a second on his clock he's
only getting one second every move both
players literally down under a second
multiple times and ultimately on draken
puts a stamp on the 5-1 portion Daniel
he has a monstrous lead going into the
3-1 he's got to be satisfied here yeah I
don't think anybody expected a
three-point lead he lost one game and
the game he lost was due to a crazy time
scramble he hasn't been outplayed a
single time and this could not have gone
better for Dimitri on draken he's got to
be happy but he can't rest on his
Laurels because three plus one that is
alirez's territorium on
yep and it's like five five plus one oh
this is Ali rezz with Terror oh three
plus one it's his territory okay bullet
is also his territory he's got a lot of
territories but draken is he was coming
in with uh a new idea a revised uh world
map
indeed and we will see how this match
progresses we hope you're loving the
2023 speed Chess Championship presented
to you by coinbase coinbase is a crypto
platform revolutionizing Financial
systems for a modern world update your
financial system to one that is
accessible decentralized and transparent
head on over to coinbase.com update the
system that's coinbase.com update the
system do it now and update your
financial system well we will be
updating the score as the three plus one
segment gets underway alireza has a lot
of coming back to do he faces a
three-point deficit against Dimitri and
draken and we will go on a short break
you are watching the speed Chess
Championship presenter by coinbase will
have an hour of three plus one coming
your way just after this break
[Music]
thank you
zip Timber Bots are here and it's time
for a Monumental Clash
Barbarian might not Crush you on the
board but he certainly can Crush you
with the board
speaking of crushing this giant is a
living Siege Tower usually found in
groups goblins are fond of sharp pointy
objects and other people's pieces
the battle heart in Valkyrie might give
you a game once she's done arm wrestling
egg Gollum
this hog rider and his Noble Steed might
give you a headache or two skeletons
adore her foes fear her you'll need to
bring your A-game if you want to be this
witch yes that probably is a rabbit up
his sleeve or a huge Fireball with your
name on it we hear Wizards are pretty
good at chess
not just a killing machine Pekka loves
tiny butterflies but you're probably not
a butterfly so watch out
the Archer Queen thinks highly of
herself and for good reason she is a
skilled tactician deadly opponent and
your worst nightmare
play them all on chess.com
but she's not gonna move it because it's
defended oh she did it
it's just so complex
we need a compilation chess.com social
media crew look through the podcast
games
[Music]
how many times I called the Moon
okay Levy you asked for it here we go
it's almost a Salesman knows what he's
doing he's gonna try to Andrea Andrea
there's a stalemate coming Pawn here
take King G4 he pushes and it's a
stalemate oh my goodness well you
clearly you I'm sure you taught Frank
about stalemate no okay
[Applause]
this I blame you for all of this this is
oh my goodness
Bishop takes Pawn takes Queen takes
loses the bishop and if that happens I
will be heartbroken because you could
have just
that was your heart heavy
is it feeling okay
her heart how is it you you can't even
script this stuff my man I
just forgot hey okay
his position is is hard to lose as long
as it stays how it is
yeah for sure
unless he starts going totally crazy
with something like pontaji
said that it
[Music]
foreign
the premier online speed chess
tournament a knockout filled with
tension drama quick tactics and shocking
moments
oh my gosh for the last seven years and
counting the best Blitz and bullet
players in the world have flocked to
chess.com to prove their worth at this
format
excitement Reigns every year with major
upsets and intense battles
this year 12 invitees and four
qualifiers face off for the title dozens
have tried but only two have ever worn
this Crown Magnus makes it look easy
wins the speed test championship
[Music]
who will be this year's Blitz King it's
time to find out
[Music]
welcome to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase
[Music]
welcome everybody back to
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship ladies and gentlemen
presented by coinbase alireza farrugia
that five plus one portion did not go
according to plan his opponent Dimitri
and draken holds a three-point lead and
Ali Reza for arugia will have to rely on
his incredible pedigree to try to
counteract and undo that lead in the
next portion Ali Reza farouza needs no
introduction to mine he is the 2022
slingfield Cup champion he is the
youngest player to surpass a 2800
classical rating and although he has not
played all that much in the last year or
so he still has an incredibly bright
future with his first SEC appearance
since 2020.
yeah and you know third place Daniel in
the bullet Chess Championship uh I heard
there's a bullet portion coming up so
you mentioned that yeah he's behind he's
gonna have to rely on you know his
pedigree skills
um that's uh pretty reliable most of the
time for him
and it hasn't been a catastrophic
failure in terms of his chess level it
feels like he's gotten pretty soundly
outplayed he's had a couple of blunders
here and there but I don't think that he
needs to catastrophize I just think he
needs to play his style try to get more
of these games into time scrambles and
maybe make some tweaks in the opening
but Dimitri has been on a tear and let's
see if he can carry that over to the
next portion are we gonna see a king's
Indian yes
yeah it's interesting because uh there
are going to be some changes I think
that the players are making based on
guess the match situation you know Ali
Reza saying okay I'm down in the match
Let's uh bring out the king's Indian
you're always happy to change it up but
also the time control I think there are
certain openings Dania that I'm sure you
can think of a few off the top of your
head they just work better given the
lower time situation
for sure I think the king's Indian I'm
totally not biased but I think it's a
pretty Wise Choice when you're down in a
match and trying to manufacture winning
chances against one D4 now A5 here is
very very standard but because white has
expanded on the king side you're
actually not worried about white plank
B4 in these types of structures so you
can actually save a Tempo sometimes on
A5 or you could play it anyway and then
play B6 and try to get that light
squared Bishop out to A6 instead I think
Reza is preparing a different kind of
expansion maybe with B5
right and if as you mentioned if you
don't play B4 you could be saving some
time here
um this looks fairly standard so I'm
actually puzzled by the question mark
that it's giving because Knight G3 looks
uh really normal here you want to stop
H5 you also want to control the F5
Square supporting E4 so many good things
about Knight G3 here and sometimes you
play G5 and then H4 and the point is to
prevent black from playing Knight H5 and
sticking his own Knight on F4 but I
think black's attack on the queen side
should alireza play B5 here might
outweigh whatever Dimitri has going on
the other side of the board instead Ali
Reza meets fire with fire this is the
standard idea in this king's Indian line
to play F6 and try to get that f file
open
right and of course you're happy to
allow Pawn takes Pawn takes as white it
opens that floor at the the H file but
are we gonna see maybe one of the most
thematic ideas here
okay he's going to start with B5 but
keep an eye out for the move Rook F4
which is such a standard exchange sack
trying to open up the bishop on G7 but
mainly to slice off the connection
between the bishop and the pawn on G5
which is essentially the only thing
holding black at bay on the on the king
side right this Pawn is doing everything
actually it's keeping like every single
piece out so as soon as you play this
it's amazing after Rook F4 I get the
feeling like I'm significantly worse
like that's my gut reaction Rook F4 as
white
yeah it's weird Dimitri has done
everything according to the textbooks
like he's positioned his pieces the way
that you're supposed to position them
he's got H4 and G5 and it feels like
he's
just actually got a terrible position
here
Brook C8
um okay I don't know about A3 it it
always comes to mind that if you play
before it'll be covered and you get the
a file this Knight on C3 is also happy
to move I don't think it needs to be on
C3 E4 is covered so could see Knight E2
good call and this is not the order I
thought we would see these two moves and
I thought black would play B4 and then
white play 92 but instead it's the other
way around will we see Dimitri chipping
away at Black's Pawn chain with A3 no
we're gonna see Rook H2 and I think he's
ultimately trying to evacuate his King
to the king side to G2
but alirez is going to prevent that from
happening
yeah straight away Bishop G4 not
happening on my watch he says there was
another move Bishop B5 which might have
been more menacing um also controlling
some some squares in here like D3 but uh
this looks very tempting right he's
completely covering the F3 square and
black is just it has to be doing well
black should be better here but Knight
G1 is an incredible
move that displays such deep
understanding of the position he wants
to go King G2 and then suddenly F3 is
going to trap the bishop on G4 I think
alireza completely missed this idea what
a move 92 to G1 and suddenly
it appears that Black's advantages
is is starting to get whittled away by
Dimitri's excellent positional play
wow yeah that's uh remarkable Bishop D1
he's saying I'm happy to trade Bishops
with you
last night starts to make an appearance
though on D4 it's always an
uncomfortable feeling because you never
really want to give away your dark
Square Bishop I I like Bishop D1 though
conceptually because it's very very hard
for black to acquiesce to the bishop
trade uh because the other Bishop of
course on G7 is you know leaves a lot to
be desired but he got the best of both
worlds I'm on and yeah Bishop B2 did not
actually stop Knight P5
that's right and I think what he wanted
was he wanted to have a knight able to
take on D4
um so that's why he's put it on F3 but
it's definitely not the square he wanted
to uh to to use on the other hand Rook a
H1 is now a very serious threat and the
attack on H7 becomes really problematic
for black how is alireza going to answer
that
he can probably go Knight D4 and
orchestrate a mass trade on the D4
square but at the end of that trade I'm
not really sure what his follow-up is
going to be Dimitri has all of the key
squares on the king side well defended
by his pieces
Bishop G4 there may there may just be
immediately Knight takes E5
um to meet that with Bishop takes
um I think after Rook H1 Bishop h8 might
have to be the reaction just you know
take me if you want and play an
interesting imbalance
and there we go and what does alireza
have in store for us and it is Knight D4
and that is why he played his Rook to E8
putting it on a closed file because he
anticipates that file opening up and
there are some crazy tactics we might
see them on with like a double capture
on e4 and then Queen takes F2 check all
hell is about to break loose yeah I
would I would show them but I think with
time so low first of all we may see some
of them appear immediately on the board
but oh my God Knight takes E4 there's
Rook takes H7 leaving the queen on pre
because of the mating pattern on h8 and
then black encounter sacrifice his Queen
and we're gonna see something very
similar after Rook takes H7
think white wins there there's a mate
threat with Rook a chain and Rook H7 oh
wow
the G5 Pawn is the hero of White's
entire attack
look at these two Pawns
take the bishop
and win the game
just take the bishop
you make it sound so easy Dania
apparently it's not maybe Knight E4 and
there's some Rook D7 oh but what is he
what is he doing he's doing what I
wanted to do he's doing what I wanted to
do
67 was game over what on Earth did he
just do that he just gave half a point
away
I don't feel
I'm not sure what to feel am I happy
that I saw the same line as him or am I
I must have led him into it
psychologically
suddenly he's the one who's got to be
careful you don't want to give up the B5
square and lose the game
oh okay thank God
yeah oh my gosh
I'm on your fault you put this into his
mind this rot he never would have done
it never I saw it on the board and I was
like I had a boy uh Dimitri well done
wow what a turnaround and man this would
have been a four point match and what a
tone this would set if Dimitri could
turn the first three minute game around
still I mean he's not unhappy with where
he is but you don't get these chances
all that outfit against alireza and as
the underdog you always need to try to
capitalize
let's go
here we go this is uh they couldn't have
had a uh better commentary uh Team for
this one
one London player and one job player
hence the Joe Bava London and here we go
so I'll I'll defer to you initially here
um Dania because first of all I like
this line for black I don't know what
you make of what we have so far but A6
has always felt me like just the the
safest looking approach not to deal with
any of this Knight B5 nonsense it's an
incredibly annoying move because it
takes the a lot of the fun out of the
jibaba which is involved with you know
get going Knight B5 at the right moment
okay alireza is playing this very
unconventionally his previous move
Knight E5 is generally not played this
early in this line instead you generally
take on C5 and reduce the tension in the
center
right and now Knight A4
okay but he's got to be very careful not
to bite off more than he can chew
yes C3 looks forced otherwise why would
you play this move yeah
um I guess he's I mean his plan is he
wants to take on C5 and say that he gets
the dark Square Bishop well I defer you
deferred to me initially now that a pawn
has reached C3 rather than a knight I
think I differ back to you because this
enters more London airspace no it's it's
it's true I feel like at this point
um as black the most solid thing that I
would say is Knight D7 Bishop E7 castle
and just yeah it might be like close to
equal maybe Black's not getting a big
Advantage but this looks just wrong for
white like give me that Knight on D2
please I don't know why it's on A4 this
is you know irking every London bone in
my body oh totally and there's no easy
way to get that night anywhere it's
totally stranded on A4 and that
increases the appeal at least for me of
playing the move C4 and just saying I'm
gonna shut out your only Escape Route
which is to take on C5 but it's also a
very committal decision and it could
backfire if white chips away at the
queen side by pushing his own beep on
either one or even two squares up the
board
right
okay he takes
this is what you want as as white I'm
pretty sure yeah Knight C5 like for
better for worse I think you want to
mess the game up like this she wants DC
before but I think he overlooked this
very powerful shot A3 and we're probably
gonna see that on the board unless Ali
Reza plays B4 here which would be a
blunder to do queen A3
but here the move A3 is pivotal
yeah that's a really cool move too
um A3 and it's like whichever on you
take I'm responding with B4
I think we should show it it's such an
instructive motif
yeah I'm gonna go back here because this
this is just a really nice move
um that you mentioned Dania A3 and I
mean let's take the more dangerous
looking Pawn uh C3 well before you
connect everything and then you can just
develop around this sure you can go win
the pawn immediately but you just need
to even just get castle
and white is actually much better here
because Black's Bishops are terrible
okay instead we went a completely
different route yeah B3 would have been
the Lesser evil best but but instead
Alias are just Danish Gambit Style Just
sacking all of his Queens all of his
Pawns in general and he's gotten
essentially a similar structure to what
we just explored except he's lacking all
of his Queen Side Pawn Yeah except he's
lacking uh what is it three pawns yeah
Bishop B5 though it feels like his
Bishops afford him serious practical
compensation right
oh my God we could get a double Bishop
sack and a draw I think we will yeah I
actually really think we will as white I
would take the opportunity to make that
drop
is three points down a micro Queen H5
here true no he's he can't resist how
can you resist such beauty
yeah it's just the the problem with uh
Ali Reza's position is he's a bit lower
on time he wanted to collect brilliancy
and he was probably fearing that you
know the worst could happen that it felt
like a position that could only go
poorly
we almost always associate the double
Bishop sack with a victory but the key
ingredient of a winning double Bishop
sack is a rook lift and the problem here
is that both of his Rooks are out of
commission they're not fast enough so he
has to satisfy himself
with a very very pretty Perpetual but a
Perpetual nonetheless in the lead will
stay at three
yeah and I think for on Drake and we've
actually seen this
I feel like he's been doing this without
me fully picking up on what's been right
in front of me the whole time but he has
been quietly amassing draw after draw
you know playing a full game out
equality he's not overpressing whenever
you know let's say in that last game he
didn't have to Castle he could have
chosen maybe like oh I'm up three pawns
let me choose an ambitious approach he
castled knowing full well he was
allowing that draw but he's happy to
he's got the advantage and it feels like
he's just playing the the match at the
moment not not necessarily the game
I I think that's very well said and
that's exactly what he's doing and he's
so comfortable in the opening it seems
like whatever alireza throws at him he's
got the perfect line prepared now
obviously the last king's Indian game
did not really go Dimitri's way
initially here I think he's skipping the
whole G4 related idea and instead
working on his minor piece development
first now of course G4 is a very
tempting move with that Knight on H5 but
we should point out that G4 can be met
with Knight F4 and as a result of that
pawn sack uh the bishop on G7 often
opens up so Dimitri needs to evaluate
that very carefully before he pushes the
Jeep on
right and the thing with the Knight on
H5 is that when F5 happens you can
almost take and consider G4 yourself as
white and that blasts everything open so
it's a weird situation for black you've
got the Knight on H5 but you can't
really play F5 and you can't really play
Knight F4 so guess what you need some
counter play here it is
so there's B3 and there's even B4 but B4
kind of shakes The Hornet's Nest a
little bit and creates in my opinion
unnecessary weaknesses on the queen side
I would go B3 yeah and maybe black wants
to meet that with Knight F4 sort of on
his own volition but instead we do see
B4
MP5 oh wow
talk about shaking The Hornet's Nest B4
B5 feels like at its core so wrong but
yeah what comes next G4 like you see
really going all out now
I don't like B4 and B5 I think the the
evaluation didn't change but he's given
black this big big Square on C5 and what
you never do in such positions is Play
Bishop takes C5 because that gives black
a monopoly on the dark squares it gives
black excellent central control so I
really don't know why Dimitri sought out
these Adventures he's probably still
better black still has a very hard time
generating chances on the queen side but
feels like now I could see this turning
in Black's favor totally
um but so my thing is that F5 I'm never
sold because takes in G4 so what about
Knight F4 if Knight takes uh Queen F6
and we actually can't really deal with
this diagonal so Knight F4 instead of F5
looks like almost the only source of
counter play
yeah I mean you could play Bishop D7 and
kick the can down the road but you're
not really preparing C6 in most cases
because the D6 Pawn is such a big
liability I've run into that so many
times uh as a king's Indian player
and instead Ali Reza just kind of
resigning himself to
what exactly I think he's trying to go
Knight D7 and Knight B6
he's taking his ball and going home what
he's doing here because I think G4 uh
Knight G3 and how would I meet Knight B6
probably with one of these Bishop moves
B3 or D3 Bishop B3 is a really cool move
because in the event of the trade you
get an A2 Square for the king I don't
know why Dimitri is contorting himself
to avoid giving up his light skirt
Bishop I would be happy to give that
Bishop away instead he's given up Knight
A4
which threatens a fork on C3 and feels
like olliraz is generating some counter
play now
so are we gonna get the pivot where
sometimes in these positions you like
you want to give up the bishop because
you take here knowing Ali Reza as soon
as this move happens he will throw in
the move E4 before white gets to you
know stick that yeah that move is gonna
be faster than you know I took the draw
for my third GM Norm
hey
but it's behind the scenes now
I did take a draw from my GM Norm by the
way
oh man there we go
you're bringing back uh the memories
there and it was the hand was out very
quick very quick faster than they could
retract the offer yeah
so you mentioned Daniel we don't want to
play Bishop takes C5 so obviously he was
kind of forced into it with F4 but I
think you'd agree it's not as bad here
just because the bishop doesn't have any
open lines yeah it's not that Dimitri
needs a review in basic positional
principles he's basically saying look
that Bishop on G7 has no Prospect
because the pawn on e4
actually white would kill to have that
pawn removed from the board because then
his own Bishop from C2 would combine
with the queen and exert pressure on H7
but as it stands blacks play on the uh
Queen side has come to a standstill and
I actually think both players are now
trying to seize control of the other
side of the board Bishop F6 preparing
Rook G8 and if black can take control of
the G file and maybe go Bishop E8 and
Bishop G6 and the knight from B6 could
move over to D6
it feels like the worst is behind him so
maybe Dimitri should meet Knight C8 by
pushing D6 and giving himself the D5
Square
right
right that's a very interesting option
and if it gets taken you know in the
right moment as you mentioned he takes
could open up on the uh the H7 Square so
dream world is we trade light Square
Bishops for white
um that's a that's a dream that still
needs a while to materialize here
okay feels like the players are kind of
running out of useful moves
or not
King takes A3 there you go there's a big
threat for you
why not then move back and start pushing
your a pawn up the board yep black might
have to go Rook A8 which is a very
embarrassing way to meet King B3 but
what else do you do the king makes this
like you know measly threat on the a
pawn and the black Army has to rethink
its entire operation it's all existence
now can you repeat moves there with
Bishop G7 and Bishop F6 he takes a
different route he trades all the Rooks
and that Queen on H6 feeling a little
bit uncomfortable
yeah uncomfortable in the sense that you
can't move but also Bishop G7 Queen G5
right
true
good point and then you can't play
Bishop F6 the bishop will be pinned
back to B3
yeah I feel like you know White's the
one that's kind of happy oh but he's
just in time to stop the progress of the
Apon once the Knight gets to D6 it feels
like black has firmly taken over the
initiative and now he's gonna win the
game because Bishop G7 and Knight F7 are
unstoppable the queen is going to be
lost
just like that just like that and it's
over
that's amazing that just happened like I
didn't even notice
it's so crazy how these games they turn
in the span of a second
wow
and he's taking all of White's pawns
Knight takes D6 and Knight E8
oh even better beautiful blockade and
now you're totally fine
everything is defended Bishop B4 look at
this oh he's got it all covered Knight
C6 King D6 and perfect timing you've
even got a pawn
and he can play A4 whenever he doesn't
even have to play A4 he can push his
other Pawn
it's over
I I like the way that you narrated that
finish it's like you knew that it was
coming and you were just doing the
play-by-play because it seemed like yeah
King takes A3 White's the one who's
happy all of a sudden Knight D6 Knight
F7 and the Queen on H6 the danger was
not he didn't recognize it it felt like
his radar was uh not going off there and
that's what happens in those positions
you feel like you own the king side and
you feel like only white can play on
that side of the board but alireza
turned it around he invited that Queen
to enter the lair and then he
beautifully arranged his minor pieces uh
to trap that Queen and and ultimately
Force Dimitri to give a minor piece away
and once again I'm on any time scrambles
I think are favoring alireza that has
been the main bright spot of his
performance that that thus far he needs
more of these long drawn out games
absolutely
um and speaking of long drawn out game
we'll probably get one here because the
Queens are off the board early
um this is an opening which optically
looks so wrong like just wrong for black
because of the doubled and isolated
pawns but
um there's a lot of different ways white
can play it you can go with like F4 to
try to shut the bishop out immediately
with F5
um sometimes even this Knight recycles
to the F or a square but very positional
game we have in front of us here yeah I
will admit that this is not sort of my
favorite line to watch but I like the
way that the game is progressing we have
a major imbalance now with a trade on C4
Dimitri expands on the queen side and
alireza does the same in the center
and there's a there's a theme that if we
see it I'll be very interested to see
how it's handled but basically if white
can achieve and he'll probably need to
play King F2 or something first but if
white can play G4 then black has the the
sensation of playing down a bishop
because you can imagine there's no F5
then and then then there's no F6 and the
bishop going back this way it just
doesn't ever get out I think you pointed
that at exactly the right moment because
it helps us understand the rationale
behind Dimitri's last move but it comes
with a big price tag now the bishop on
G6 is poorly supported and alireza could
try to get his knight from C3 to E2 to
F4 and exert serious pressure on that
Bishop push it back to the even more you
know ungodly Square H7
right yeah it's all about the Maneuvers
here and truthfully the knights are
better at maneuvering so yeah uh Knight
D1 ID3 Knight F5 is another one
um looking at White's position I feel
like if you could get a knight to F5
you're home free
totally and that night is heading to F4
feels like Dimitri has lost the thread
here
um I agree not just in this game but
maybe even in the match but let's see if
alireza can convert what is at this
point it is beautifully a big Advantage
good call I think by Dimitri to muddy
the waters he pushes F5 this might might
have been the last opportunity he had to
do so
totally and this is why I uh perhaps to
a fault may have operated uh a little
bit slower as white and not just rushed
into this because I would want to
prevent any like you know semblance of
an F5 move because leaving that Bishop
locked in there is to me it feels like
White's whole advantage in a nutshell is
that Bishop being locked in
the ship takes H4 now runs into F takes
G6 but then the bishop can calmly step
back to G5 and the point is that white
is up a pawn but the threat of Bishop
takes F4 and that's a positional threat
because it ruins White's Pawn structure
gives black
enough counter play I think for the drum
agreed yeah and you say draw but I'm
quietly wondering if it's more than that
yeah it might be black there who's
flirting with uh
with the with the pressure
interesting decision he definitely has
more to play for here but so does his
opponent
um Ali Reza took a you know very very
double-edged approach with GH he's
trying to situate his Rook on E5 but
then the bishop calmly steps back to G6
and it seems like Black's got everything
under control there
I think if you say that the bishop
calmly retreats to G6 it soothes it
soothes the the player you know it's
like oh Bishop G6 uh defensive move
sucks but oh no I'm calmly gonna play it
calm defensive move but on the inside
you're you're panicking and you're
knocking on the door of disaster he's
gone the other way he's got an f8 and
the drawback of that this is a subtle
point but the C6 Pawn could be a problem
in some situations instead we get a rook
trade or a a minor piece trade rather
and Dimitri activates his Rook
yeah also Rook takes Rook
um captures on H2 Brook age eight to me
is this maybe a slight issue I'm trying
to evaluate that position but
I don't yeah we're likely going to get
an exchange of one pair of Rooks one way
or the other it it feels to me
Eric H2 Shaq takes and maybe like Rook
A3 or D5 and then Rook A3
yeah there are some storm clouds kind of
gathered around Black's King alireza
pushing D5 he wants to trade everything
on D5 and then take on B5 and get
excellent winning oh and he's gonna take
d8 and take with check and this might be
losing for black this is essentially the
same thing as if he played Rook h8 took
the rook and then after D5 black took
which you would never play in that line
like it would be just ludicrous but he
tricked him into it just so crafty now
he can take and go Rook V8 and take on
A7 as well I think it's over I think
olly Reza is sitting there thinking wait
what am I missing but he's not missing
anything Rook takes B5 go after the a
pawn and then black can't even get the F
Pawn in return because white will be
able to defend it from A3 and this is
resignable just like on the spot totally
and truthfully you might not even need
to
think further than that right like once
The Rook gets to A3 I think you're done
calculating
and Dimitri at the time there to figure
out the proper defensive approach he
obviously overlooked Rook h8 check he
assumed that the trade on D5 was forced
and he actually is going to win the F
Pawn but it's going to be a moot point
if alireza plays this correctly
that's right I actually didn't notice
that he was able to do that so draken
for fighting on there me neither don't
worry a two two connected pass pawns is
enough to win because essentially white
will use the Rook to sack for the pawn
uh eventually down the line and then
these two pawns will be
Unstoppable yeah that's just one of
those ideas you have to be super
familiar with you cannot be afraid of
Black's passport I would try King E5
here but white can beat him to the punch
maybe with King C5 the right moment such
as right now yeah such as any moment
and B6
yeah Rook a a A4 King B6 and you know
once everybody gets cozy together it
feels a little bit better well said ping
A6
and you don't even need the a pawn
that's the kind of interesting thing
about the way alirez is converting this
he's actually just relying on his King
to support the bee pawn and Dimitri lets
his time run out what a conversion by
alireza farouza taking that from equal
to winning in the span of five seconds
and it feels like he's had this lead and
brought it to one point in the span of
five seconds where is that three point
lead that we were talking about so you
you blinked in the three plus one
portion and that lead is gone like
banished
um and on draken he feels it too because
remember that strategy that he was using
maybe consciously were subconsciously
but he was basically playing the match
it felt like happy to take a draw not
overpressing advantages now that's all
well and good but as soon as it flips on
his head and you're the one that needs
to stop the bleeding or get some results
that strategy will not work forever
this is a huge game I mean this game is
going to do so much for Dimitri's
confidence if he can strike back with a
victory bring this lead back up to a
safer number whereas imagine a victory
for alireza his third in a row I think
this is a watershed moment in the match
so the opening is particularly important
I think alireza is making his intentions
very clear with his last move
age five I mean it's kind of a uh
Unwritten or written rule that you play
H5 H4 against the fianchetto setup when
there's no night uh situated on on F3 or
F6 why stop there
let's go H3 H2 there we go there we go
continues
yeah this feels like how like all of my
bullet games when I'm on tilt go and I
just see flies up the board well I
usually do it on move one two and three
and when I play H6 it just blunders the
knight uh blunders the pawn to the night
or he may be interested in the move C5
um which looks like a weakening move but
it's kind of trading squares the
interesting thing for white is although
E3 is so tempting down the line in order
to do it like 95 E3 you're always
risking this bishop uh G4 kind of uh
move
good call C5 supporting the Knight the
Knight on E3 is sort of tied to its
place although not really you can play
Knight E to D5 and Bishop F5 will come
with Tempo but it's not such a scary
move I can drop the queen back and
ultimately you do want to play E3 you
don't want to live with this Knight on
D4 sitting on you forever so it feels
like Dimitri doing a really good job of
sort of working his way around alirez's
active pieces
so far I like the move Queen A5 my
Outlook on this position is like I'm I'm
almost starting to really hate Black's
position so we have to make sure that
we're covering this and that's why I
thought Queen A5 was so clever because
believe it or not that a two Pawn I mean
it's time to take it in some lines for
sure I mean it's you can take it right
now
but then you have to reckon with Bishop
takes D4 Knight C7 you obviously are
also considering Bishop F5 which would
be consistent with the way alireza has
played this game he's banking on his
piece activity and I think Bishop F5 is
an ollie Reza kind of move but no
he clearly hasn't had his had his
breakfast yet today
this this is gonna be fun though
um very
I feel like you throw that move in you
do because you're not in a rush to play
Knight C7 right
now Bishop F5 or Bishop G7
both
exactly
Knight C7 here we go
[Music]
yeah you're I think yours is um yours is
a bit better just you're trying to just
Feast on all the pawns yeah I want to
take B3 and C4 we've seen a couple of
these exchange sacks I mean we saw one
from Dimitri in that Italian game where
it's really not such a big commitment
because you've got so many pawns for the
exchange
um but Bishop C3 is also tempting
because if you can induce Rook E2 then
you have ideas like Bishop F5 to G4
later on so definitely something to chew
on here for alireza who's under a minute
but man it never feels like he's in time
pressure even when he's got two seconds
yeah it's like it's it unlocks him ooh
okay so he goes for the more like you
know the stable approach
why doesn't this sound stable it does
look very unstable I mean Knight takes
Aid Bishop D5 and queen F3 and it seems
like a
very very nasty setup and white doesn't
even have to take one of the Rooks you
can you can wait until black moves the
one of the Rooks and to take the other
one
that's right and I think that's why
Bishop D5 is such a strong move in its
own right because in in a crazy way of
thinking I want to do your idea with
Queen F3 like don't actually need to
grab this Pawn I can play G4 and if
Queen V3 I have like Rook D1 right after
after June 4th so
but now G4 runs into Bishop D3 and this
is a very important detail because that
might mean Dimitri has to go E4 but that
gives up the D4 Square for the dark
squared Bishop somehow alireza actually
feels a lot more stable than a couple
minutes ago yes exactly good sound
effects poster boy for stability
[Laughter]
Queen A3 keep contact with the pawn
this is yeah A6 B5 King G7 and that pawn
on H3 it it looks like it always drops
off but yeah but never quite does yeah
it's like that it's like the one that
just never dies exactly and even when it
does die to pick it up white would have
to go G4 and make these massive holes on
the king side
Bishop takes E6 could be met with Rook
takes E6 and that Rook will reshuffle
over to F6
feels to me like practically speaking
black is better but maybe I'm influenced
by the course of the match right man it
feels like alireza has a chance right
now to strike for the third time in a
row and tell me why when I have a Pawn
on H6 it always just falls off and when
my phone has a Pawn on H3 I'm always
mated
Rick Andale reservarusia effect man and
okay he loses his patience like I need
to get this chance to respond off the
board and a great decision by Dimitri
this really allows him to breathe and
is running out of ideas here yeah
he's trying to lock things up like
Bishop E5 G5 I will say at the right
moment here we may see a rook sacrifice
back for the bishop on D4 something like
that apparently E5 is the best move
nobody's ever playing that in a thousand
years
but now the opportunity train has left
the station
Queen takes C4 now better blonde to take
and then you take A4 just mopping the
floor on the Queen's I know black is
better here in a Time scramble I take
black 10 times out of ten yeah
C4 push him baby
okay B7 okay I see two c two
C2 Rook C7 Queen A3 alireza goes
prophylactic style of King G7 just kind
of keeping the status quo what about
Rook E3 Rook F3 that's the idea in a
time oh my gosh she's it's winning it's
winning he can't defend F7
H4 any wins on time wow
unbelievable it's actually crazy to
think that H4 that was the move that
that maybe lost the advantage at the end
but one on time
oh my goodness it did win on time
apparently Queen C1 and that final
position would have kept practical
chances for black but it's a moot point
Rook E3 Rook F3 what in a clutch idea in
a Time scramble
and I
I think I just saw as you know uh Andre
can really brought one back there in
that final game I think I just saw him
get up and uh is he wearing pajamas
there I mean his chest is definitely not
putting us to sleep here Daniel that was
a super exciting game imbalances from
both players both guys are really
playing to win it feels like in these
final moments I can't wait for the
bullet because quite literally it's
gonna decide this match no this has been
an incredible SEC match and every time
we think that we have a good handle on
who's got the momentum and where the
match is going boom something unexpected
happens in that case Dimitri on Drake
and pulled out a very difficult position
and added to his lead he now holds a
two-point lead down from three but still
very impressive given how far Advanced
we are in the match Dimitri and draken
leads alireza for Russia eight to six
we'll be back with more SEC action in
just a couple of moments
thank you
chess.com's game review recently got a
major update here are four key notes at
the end of each game review you will now
see a summary of the game from your
coach your performance rating for that
game and a quick grade for you and your
opponent in the opening middle game and
in game we've added a new classification
called Miss for when a move fails to
take advantage of an opportunity but it
is otherwise a sound move we've also
changed the definition of blunder now a
move will only be considered a blunder
if it loses material or allows a
Checkmate coach will now draw arrows and
highlight squares when you hover over or
click on the highlighted words in the
move explanations this should make move
explanations easier to follow finally
coach's explanations will now reference
specific pieces and threads in
explanations making move explanations
much more intuitive the new game review
variants is available on chess.com right
now
[Music]
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the Champions chess tour to
the candidates speed chess championship
title Tuesday feed a world championship
and so much more chess.com events has
all of the top chess tournaments played
both over the board and online
and review games from the world's
greatest players with live commentary
cloud analysis opening Explorer and
table bases find all the key event
information including schedules prizes
results news reports player bios tie
breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Championship presented by coinbase
Dimitri on draken holds a two-point lead
over the third seated alireza faruja he
leads eight points to six but we have
another 30 minutes or so of three plus
one Blitz left to play come on it's been
a topsy-turvy match it's been a very
unpredictable match ultimately a super
impressive showing by ondraken so far in
the first two hours
and it's been so exciting what we've had
a chance to watch here more exciting
than what Ali Reza was looking at
outside of his window
he's just standing man man at window you
know this is a great poetic moment there
is he's just reflecting on the match I
think he's also gonna swing very
peacefully kind of billowing in the wind
geez that that's a movie shot right
there it totally is man that view out of
that window must be absolutely
breathtaking
I think he heard you
she definitely did is like I'm getting
off cameras the commentator can't have
the satisfaction
of uh
pointing anything out and instead we're
looking at Dimitri on Dragon he's
chewing something
if you think that this is what I'm
missing you know why I'm not 3 500
bullets do I need to be staring out
windows before my bullet matches
apparently so well whatever he was
staring at hopefully gives him
inspiration because Ali Reza just lost a
pretty painful game winning that game
would have allowed him to tie the match
instead he's back to a two-point deficit
but he's got the white pieces he's been
more successful with the white pieces in
the three minute portion and let's see
if he can keep that positive play going
yeah this is uh definitely uh I think
the format where pre-match you would
probably say oh yeah Ali Reza massive
favorite and this is where you expect
him to rack up the points and that could
very well be true but uh based on how
the match has gone I think that always
colors the uh the bullet portions so
we'll have to finish off this this three
minute Daniel but uh the the bullet is
looming and andrekin knows that he's got
to make sure he stays in this match it's
interesting how many times they've
repeated you know the same openings and
the same ideas
of course the ball is very much in
alirez's court when it comes to this
line because we remember uh the first
time that they played this and they're
almost verbatim repeating the line I
think not quite I mean fair alireza was
relying on D4 here he's relying on the
more direct Queen side pressure with A4
and B4
he stayed away from the move G5 this
time and it feels like right when Ali
Reza tries to get back in this match
winning games in a row uh ondrakin is
right there just to shut the door right
when you think that uh farusha is gonna
run away with it so you know it's just
been such an entertaining match Honestly
by by both guys here so we're really in
for a treat as we see knight d8 uh such
a weird looking move but he was
obviously still thinking G5 and maybe to
reroute the Knight D6 it makes me eat my
words is Ali Reza I said he's relying on
B4 no he's got the burger and the mac
and cheese and the fries you know order
everything B4 and D4 yeah but Knight H5
is obviously very very typical move in
any such positions D takes E5
Knight takes G3
I guess I could gobble up the D6 Pawn
but that I don't know why doesn't that
work
takes Knight takes
um takes off
whoa we have to show this and then white
has E5 and the reason white has E5 is
because
[Laughter]
single control of this position here
if you play H takes G3 there's Queen
takes G3 this is what black was banking
on this is probably why Reza didn't play
uh Ed but you have E5 another Intermezzo
chase the queen away then take the
Knight and you're basically up upon for
no compensation you're almost winning
right
big Miss yeah what what a uh what a line
there King H1 played Knight to F4 but
this is what andrekin is looking for
from the opening not to say like he has
a massive advantage or anything but
this is what he's looking for I feel
like white is still much better too many
weak squares right the D5 Square can be
accessed after Bishop takes Knight the
F5 square is a weakness and black just
hasn't really started the engine on the
king side and the way that he would want
to
a lot of people would uh definitely hey
oh God the chat's never gonna let me
forget this this they're gonna have a
field day right now they just got their
utensils out you know like yeah the bib
is going on Fresh comments from Dania
yeah they sound like a steak lying on
the lying in the gutter you know gotta
pick that up and
you know just flopping across the chin
oh Ollie Rose is tongue is flopping
across his chin as evidenced by his last
move Dimitri trying to keep the queen
side closed I think A5 is a very good
move you've got to keep that AFL close
so that you can castle queenside at some
point
and will we see Bishop takes F4 I think
that is the big decision alirez has to
make do you try to get a knight to D5 I
vote Yes I think that this is a great
opportunity to do so
yeah and there's um there's even the
idea like uh Knight D5 let's say Knight
takes you could even consider Pawn takes
with an idea like rookie one and mass uh
captures and sacrifices on E5 remember
that King is still in the middle
but he's gone the other way he's gone to
F5 and queen H7 is a nice little square
for the Queen instead he goes back to f8
Knight coming to C4 and hitting the A5
Pawn
and it's actually it's quite annoying um
it looks like nothing but nothing is
also happening on the king side like H5
we need to uh get some pawns going if
not white is going to calmly go Knight
C4 and I mean you're never gonna play B6
there so it's pretty hard to stop
and alireza just clearing the air on the
king's side and transitioning over to
the queen side here comes the other
the other Pony and if black plays B6
well I'm not gonna comment on that move
at all
that's enough right there
okay but H5 is the reason it's not scary
is because white can always just play
Bishop takes F4 so H4 isn't even a
threat and nothing reveals that like Ali
Reza's last move but maybe there's
Knight takes G2
okay yeah that was actually uh I think a
big moment so you were spot on there
um H4 perhaps a little rushed you could
better go Knight takes G2 and then H4 to
traffic Edition
H3 there by all the rest is such a small
move
um you know what's that one small or
giant leap for mankind one small step
but what that move does is it prevents H
it prevents black from playing H3 and it
establishes a defensive post for White's
Queen on F3 where everything will be
covered black will have absolutely no
chances to create counter play on the
king side I think Dimitri's busted here
yeah it's like it's the kind of busted
where you just it slowly sets in because
like yeah you can dream of g-file
pressure but truthfully the bishop on A7
is dead
um you can't even use the G8 Square so
it's difficult to make a single threat
I mean what's going on on the queen side
what's just like looting and taking
everything he wants and just dropping
the Knight back calmly to C4
yep
yeah Knight C4 looks fantastic here
okay Dimitri obviously gonna continue to
try to muddy the waters he can now play
Rook GA congrats he made a mate in one
thread the attack is now over
a little too much on the Tabasco sauce
there
your point is well taken though yeah
that could be a single threat is it you
know like white just sits here defends
G2 and says great you got one Target and
it's defended so Oman do you think black
has any realistic chances on on the king
side I don't think we've made it clear
what the prospects are for black on the
G file well I'll tell you what he's
intending I I got that figured out Rogue
G3 I think yeah he's he's looking for
Rook G3 but as long as alireza is just
got his wits about him I mean there's
this is oh my God Queen D5 I mean oh
rookie eight uh rookie Rook d8 he's
still he's still fighting
with what I'm curious in uh you know in
his in his Symphony black pieces have
all of themselves oh look at the ba
Queen and Rook A7 check
all right Dimitri I think this is enough
suffering
in a weird way this was it really was
the most one-sided game that we've
actually maybe seen right in in the
whole match and it feels weird to say
that because we saw that opening before
but the way that game went it felt like
alireza was just calling every Bluff
it's like okay you want to attack me
over there you're gonna Gambit this Pawn
you're gonna Gambit two pawns sure and
it just never panned out this was
alirez's best game in the match so far
it was only raza's cleanest game of the
match you called it and the way that he
picked apart any semblance of attack
that Dimitri was hoping to achieve on
the king side and the way that he
maneuvered his Knights giving one away
and then using the other one to take all
the black's pawns on the other side of
the board I mean if you want to study
the Italian this game should go straight
into the textbooks well done by alireza
the Dimitri still leads and we've been
in this situation before the first time
Dimitri struck with a crucial Victory
before the break and he pull it off a
second time
so E4 uh you know you dream of getting a
knight to C3 but it's just not gonna
happen so you kind of have to say okay
you're gonna get your Pawn back with
Queen A5 and takes but white is
truthfully far ahead in development and
that's that's the biggest asset for on
draken right now I think Knight C3 was
very Hasty though Queen A3 essentially
forces either a queen trade or a trade
on D5 which rectifies Black's Pawn
structure and allows that knight from B8
to come out to C6 alireza not taking
that opportunity and now I feel like
white is once again sort of stably
slightly better but it's a nagging
Advantage yep
yeah it's it's just like the bishop on
C8 actually won't uh develop really for
most of this game I imagine because it's
doing such an important and great job
um defending the pawn on B7
Knight C5 division of labor
exactly this is like you know when
you're doing some spring cleaning and
someone wants to help you don't really
want their help but you want to let them
participate it's like okay you're great
where you are yeah Bishop on C8 Queen H6
I was literally gonna point this out
that C5 runs into Queen H6
and it's a miracle the black isn't mated
there he has F6 and Rook F7 just in the
nick of time
I was gonna say yeah please give it
double exclamation marks because Queen
D2 looks like you're just getting out of
the way of Knight A4 but totally totally
planned here Rook H4 Brook here and you
might get sidetracked thinking about 95
Bishop D5 but as you mentioned exactly
barely hanging on I think it is
worthwhile to move the knight from F3
but maybe to a defended square like D2
and simultaneously work on getting it to
a productive spot on the queen side
Knight D2 is a very Dimitri on Dragon
kind of move I think I think we're
likely to see something like that
yeah
yeah Bishop is going to arrive on E6
maybe just anyway
um but if you move the Knight you at
least hit the B7 pawn and you know
Bishop D5
pressure on V7 I like this position a
lot it feels like the pieces here are
just
side sidelined
though to take the other perspective
what's annoying about such positions is
that you feel like you need to squeeze
the maximum you feel like this is my
chance you know I've got optimally
placed pieces and it's so easy to burn a
ton of time you know going down the
rabbit hole of various tactics which I
think is kind of what Dimitri is doing
here he's got to keep a close eye on his
clock because he's been up on time in
most of these middle games but here he's
almost down a minute now
and I'm trying to almost keep the attack
alive like maybe bishop E4 is a future
move to sack on G6
Knight C3 but Queen A3 and suddenly
Black's pieces are kind of suspended in
midair right like if you play Knight
takes A2 you drop the c Pawn with Tempo
Queen takes A2 drops the Knight
feels like black is super uncoordinated
discombobulated I don't know what the
best word is and queen E3 was totally
planned like he knew Knight C3 was
coming he had Queen E3 ready it's always
a nice way to calculate it's just like
yeah one step ahead of your opponent so
that you're always thinking on their
time the Queenie through is played
faster than you know college student
grabs the last donut in a dorm like that
move was shot out of a cannonball
I mean A3 Rook C
492 no not possible
C2 apparently yeah Queen C1 is a
slightly problematic threat better way
of doing that tactic so do not play Rook
C4
Rook C2 Rook C2 is a very calm move yeah
and the second rank defense is really
effective he blundered it no way
the second insane blunder of the day
maybe even more insane than they made in
one honestly is on draken as bad as me
or am I as good as on draken you're
definitely no I'm draken is as good as
you I mean let me spin that a third way
why why have I been so spot on with
blunders like the exact thing not to do
it's crazy and and what's happened with
both of these big blunders right the
maiden one is you so the seeds of the
idea then I say just to be clear this
move should not be played and that's
precisely when both players have made
the move that's really too bad like
these are the kind of things that
truthfully almost every single player
might think of it's one thing to think
of it but then realize oh wait Queen C1
I'm being I'm just forgetting uh that
move but andrekin is seeing it probably
but just not noticing that extra step
because he I think he saw 92 but not the
other way around Queen C1 first you know
to me when these blunders happen in time
scrambles they're totally understandable
like when you've got two seconds all
you're thinking about is not losing on
time when the players have over 30
seconds and they blunder something like
this it's pretty shocking is it nerves
is it fatigue it's hard to say but it
just shows that everybody's human we're
all human this happens and it's now
happened once for each player so we're
essentially Square
yeah exactly Rook D7
that's a good way to put it perfect
segue
as on draken has pretty much handed this
to his opponent but he's got nothing to
lose now right he's he's already he
knows he's messed it up so with 20
seconds left test for rouge's technique
and while you're doing it calm yourself
down for the next game right this also
serves the purpose of allowing him to
breathe and allowing him to to gear
himself up for the next game which is
going to be even more important than
this one because he's going to be
staring down the barrel of a tide match
assuming that alireza can complete the
conversion which he undoubtedly will
yeah Rook takes D3 was possible there
yeah it's kind of a weird tactic but
um
I don't know if I fully trust this Rook
B8 I would play immediately yeah it's a
little bit dicey
but I think
it's like not totally inspires
confidence a rickety Bridge you know
over a ravine kind of thing it probably
won't break but it actually might after
Bishop C6
wow Bishop C6
that was the move
oh my God he was handed a chance on a
golden platter Rook B4 is the idea he's
and now it's on this could be tricky
right Rook Rook B7
because if Bishop D7 there was Knight F5
oh my God and he's gonna win both Rooks
but Black's gonna promote oh my goodness
and the Knight is just not
this is not doing enough
he's still fighting it's like again the
last using his last tentacle the other
seven have been chopped off but unless
alireza blunder is a fork this one's
over
ah this is not as easy as you'd think
yeah
Bishop H3 though I would essentially try
to surround again you like work around
White's pieces go Bishop G4S
it's not as easy as you think it is what
was that
yeah it's not as easy as you think it is
me on the other hand I think it's very
easy we weren't talking about you you're
as good as on Drake and we already
established that earlier exactly okay
well you called it Daniel tied up
um this match is now I called it eight
yeah the fact that it's even tight is a
miracle now that alireza missed Bishop
C6 there that would have drawn the game
it would have and it would have been
like the perfect diffuser for the the
momentum that uh that he's built up here
with this comeback now to come back from
a blunder like that would have been
insane but we're past that now
uh we are past Dimitri on draken's lead
and this is a zero zero match
what a match it's been and what a match
is going to continue being
yeah and
um it's interesting that he immediately
quote unquote fixed uh what happened
last time remember those g5s like he
actually got beaten so badly
it was the most one-sided game of the
match immediately he's gone to a more
standard e45 but Ali Raza is so good in
these positional Italians I mean he's
won one game after another against top
GMS he's so fluent in the language of
the Italian moves like Bishop C4 to D5
these are not moves that you come up
with on the spot these are moves that
you study these are moves that you know
and they're incredibly problematic
because you can't take with a knight you
drop a minor piece if you had taken to
the bishop then the e-pawn would have
sent the Knight back to B8 where it goes
anyway but I think Dimitri is trying to
go C6 but he's not in time to do that
and alireza is once again on the move
here putting serious pressure on the
board and on the clock
yeah if you take on uh D4 I'm wondering
if you take on E6 there but even Knight
takes D4 would be be dressed as well
I feel like we're knocking on the door
of this kind of spinning out of control
for Dimitri it feels like he's starting
to lose the grasp of some of these games
yep and by the looks of it it's going to
be very very close uh with the match
clock whether we get another game as
well
um so I'm not sure if either player is
going to be thinking about that maybe
later on towards the end of this game
but this is maybe going to be the first
lead for Ali Reza if he's able to pull
this off right
it will be it's been a wire to wire lead
so far for Dimitri
this is the first tie since uh
well since I want to say half half
first ties into
tied
so that first side exactly
oh this Knight on B8 is just yearning
for some opportunities in this position
but Bishop B2 like do we care about this
move keep the Knight locked in with that
pawn on D5 here yeah that pawn on D5 is
like an object lying on the power button
of your computer like you're just not
getting anything out ever
and that pawn is also severing the the
coordination between the two sides of
the board so like Knight C7 Knight E3
and that night on C7 is again at a dead
end
yep
you can never access the other side of
the board which the attention could
easily switch to normally you'd think
Bishop f8 you know no problem but Knight
F5 is is gonna be really nasty there
and we can see how how much more quickly
Ali res is playing you can sense his
confidence increasing with every win and
this is what we were talking about
before the match when he gets into his
zones he's totally Unstoppable
especially in the faster time controls
let's see if you can convert this big
Advantage Bishop F6 okay
still holding on is on draken but Russia
could play one of those slow improving
moves like Rook C1 and put even more
pressure on Black's position
yeah I agree Rook C1 Rook do you want
like these simple moves and steady goes
for F3 which should
I mean nearly force uh Bishop takes here
I can't really think another move
because you move the Knight and then
just takes F6 impossible
now Knight H6 is very tempting but I I
don't think that's necessarily squeezing
the maximum out of the position believe
it or not
because of what rookie 395 I actually
think after Knight H6 King H7 black but
you basically give black a Tempo but no
Dimitri's on tilt let me just completely
yeah
oh not enough not even which he missed
he clearly missed Queen H6
because truthfully if Queen E4 had to
happen yeah there was I mean it was
completely fine for black for sure now I
think the wide open King coupled with
the extra Pawn shouldn't give white a
technically winning position although
obviously black has this d-pawn which is
supported by both of his heavy pieces
Ali Reza doesn't give a darn about it
he's taking all the black spawns now I
have seen a number of positions where
remarkably you you're like down three
pawns like four pawns like I'm almost
exaggerating this point but not really
far as possible and then it's like wait
you tie down an entire Rook to its
defense the problem is white spawns are
not self-sufficient they need the
support of at least one piece I think
we're seeing this narrative
coming to fruition after Queen D3 one
thing Dimitri has to avoid is blundering
Queen G5 like Queen E6 Queen G5 drops
The Rook but he's doing exactly what you
prescribed him on the Rook has died down
the White Queen is also kind of tied
down because the king is really really
vulnerable to checks uh along the A7 G1
diagonal
might not matter like you you could just
be playing Queen E2 next and say okay
like I don't care about this Rook as
long as I get yours one Pawn makes the
difference here
which is why I think we're gonna see
King H7
and apparently it's not accurate but I
would throw the eval bar out of the
window this is really really hard to
play for alireza hard to play actually
that is totally
oh that is a scary scary looking move
yeah because Queen C2
draw
that just forces a draw
yeah I think Queen H5 Queen G5 will be
the uh the draw obviously you can never
go back and lose your local check
and Knight takes H6 check I mean even
though Dimitri's response to that move
wasn't accurate I guess the culprit was
Queen takes A7 that was the overly
greedy move alireza underestimating the
power of that pawn once it reached E2
and he's now forced to seek a prevention
four uh if you know if you want to just
test the waters here because truthfully
Queen E4 that's the move that you know
if you get it you win the game is he
gonna play F when I don't not see him
playing F4 that would just be flirting
with major disaster especially because
you're cutting your queen off it's not
like you play F4 and you still have a
draw if you want like no after F4
sorry buddy you're not that's ship life
sailed exactly and he played it Madness
that's just madness he wants to win so
bad and truthfully that's the difference
on draken would have taken that draw
he's shown in this match that's sort of
how he plays
um so live by the sword Die By The Sword
I'm nitpicking but I don't love Queen
takes A4 I think this gives White's
Queen a lot of Leverage and I think
alireza has gotten a second opportunity
to repeat moves there's 10 seconds on
the match clock and now Dimitri goes for
it he's trying to escape by the other
side
but he should be playing like pretty
freely here I don't actually
uh the match clock is expired as well so
we are actually going into the bullet
tied up at eight and a half and on
draken I mean we we have to say we've
talked about what furuja has done this
match Dimitri on Drake and just saved
himself from being down going into the
bullet
yeah that was an incredible save I mean
obviously he's gonna be disappointed if
you had told faruja this would be a tied
match going to the bullet I think he'd
be okay with that I think he's a lot
more okay with that given that he was
he's been down as much as three points
could have even been down four points at
one point in this match so Ali Reza's
got to be thrilled with the fact that he
has a a clean slate he's got 30 minutes
of bullet to play and uh let's be real
Dimitri and draken will have to step it
up in a big way and one of the things
that you can use to step your
performance up in a big way is ag-1 a
new partner of the SCC ag1 is your daily
support of key Health functions for
mental performance to energy and the
immune system it's the one product that
does the work of many to find out more
visit
drinkag1.com chess that's drinkag1.com
chess or use x Glam ag1 in the chat and
uh let's see lovely photo of Danny
holding he's drinking the uh chess.com
flavor I see yeah of course green
flavored performance enhancer ag1 we
think ag-14 being a partner of the SEC
and we thank alireza and Dimitri for
being tied going into the bullet segment
oops you're watching the speed Chess
Championship it's gonna be a thrilling
final 30 minutes and we will be back
with the final portion of the SEC
determine the winner on the other side
of this short break
thank you
[Music]
chess kit is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kit
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest bustles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
did you know you can add Emoji to your
online games and Analysis boards simply
click on the Emoji palette icon select
your emoji and left click on the board
you can choose from a host of notations
animations emoticons and even your
favorite chess personalities
emoticons it will fade away after a few
seconds
however notations and special animations
remain on the board until they are
cleared to clear them simply left click
on the Emoji or hit the clear all button
at the bottom of the palette
have fun try them all on chess.com
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
was just on camera there he is
he escaped now he's back sitting back
down he will need to bring his A-game to
the table here at the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase we
are two segments in to his match against
Dimitri on draken it is all tied up
going into the bullet segment now
there's no denying that alireza is a
heavy favorite when it comes to his
bullet pedigree a third place finish at
the most recent bullet Chess
Championship and just all around amazing
bullet play for the last many many years
by alireza yeah I mean you look at his
road to third place and it's like uh
actually won a match against Magnus then
lost a rematch lost to Hikaru like when
your losses are to Magnus and Hikaru
third place is yeah that pretty much
cements you right there third best in
that tournament that's super impressive
and guess what that is what andrekin is
up against right now I think it's fair
to say he knows he's an underdog Danya
but he's he's got every chance on draken
is a very experienced bullet player back
in the ICC days he played one plus zero
regularly unfortunately he's played much
less in the last couple of years he
needs a lot of speed he needs tactical
Acumen and he needs the openings to go
his way Dimitri will have to put in one
of the best 30 minutes of his bullet
existence if he wants to win this match
and we are off ladies and gentlemen it's
all tied it's zero zero we've got 30
minutes to determine the winner of this
fascinating match
yeah and you know one of the the things
that I've noticed sometimes is that the
players you least expect to be maybe
proficient in Bullet For example on
Drake in here I've often surprise you
with their speed yeah so I wouldn't be
surprised to see andrekin actually keep
the pace up here
yeah I mean again just to harken back to
on draken's ICC days he was one of the
highest rated bullet players on the side
he was competing with Hikaru pretty
regularly and his rating was you know in
the like 3700s or something crazy like
that so this is not a pushover this is
not a walkover for alireza and he's not
thinking of it that way as we see a sort
of a slob here alireza grabbing the pawn
on C4 and I think he's gonna cling to it
potentially with Bishop A6 no he's gonna
he and keto the bishop to B7
I think in bullet uh Pawn sacrifices for
obvious reasons the value just goes up
like white yeah we want to take this
Pawn back but if we don't it's not the
end of the world whereas in a five
minute game I might be more stressed
about that
okay well now Bishop A6 is still on the
table I I would not give up the C4 Pawn
easily in bullet you want to make your
opponent think you want to pose constant
problems that's precisely what alirez is
doing in the early going really like the
way he's playing that night has to be
eliminated ASAP
good call you have to take that even
though it gives up the dark squares
um I think people are happy to uh oh
happy to lose a F4 that's not part of
the plan no it is not I mean white has
to try Knight D6 here and establish past
Pawn of his own on E6 but same idea as
last game yeah yeah D7
I mean it's a bullet game anything can
happen but that pawn is very effectively
disarmed by Queen D7
so Queen uh D2 hitting the Knight then I
think
that is a that is a knife
yeah Knight D3 really really hurts so
maybe
I was thinking of 94 but it doesn't even
work we wanted the E4 Square for
different pieces oh
that's a nice idea very very tricky
because F7 is going to fall with check
the problem is you don't have Queen f8
there which would have been a back rink
made because of the placement of black
screen so all the Reza can safely take
the bishop right the queen f8 is like
everybody's favorite puzzle Rush active
yeah in the first like the one featured
in the first 25 puzzles consecutively
Rook F5 okay so the one thing that he's
doing here is he's watching over the B5
Square uh okay whoa look at Dimitri
actually developing some massive counter
play on the king side I mean this could
end up a Checkmate after Knight D5 look
at this queen takes three to 97 would be
a chance to redeem himself for the
tactic that he missed yes it's a huge
threat exact same thing Knight F4
another great move
Rook D5 and he's gonna be winning yeah
that's amazing
oh my gosh G6 and queen takes G8 all
sorts of threats here and a four got E7
take G8
same thing same thing because the Rook
will be out of squares Queen G6 wins the
queen or this wow nice move what a
finale look at this look at this he
played like an engine in the last 15
moves so he really did that was like
exclamation mark move after exclamation
mark and to do that in bullet this is
what I was saying like I mean Ali Reza
needs to wake up in the bullet portion
often the the stronger players the more
experienced they start off a little bit
slowly I don't remember who it was it
was maybe Abraham Lincoln who said that
the the bullet players you least expect
uh sometimes come up with uh the
strongest performances so I think very
wise words however uttered whoever
uttered that phrase
uh uh Abe he was a he was a good one Abe
Hamilton
the president
abrahambleton
not bad on the Fly and Rook another Rook
on G4 we've already had a rook on G4 in
the game that went very wrong for
Dimitri now I like this strategy in
bullet but again that Eternal pin
against the Knight can be very hard to
deal with within the confines of uh a
bullet King
but that's also you know precisely why
Andre can felt more comfortable to go
back to it because you remember he
actually gave it up he was like no no
like I lost such a bad game there I
don't want to even play this anymore but
now that it's bullet he says okay uh
that looked a little messy and Blitz
let's see you defend it with less time
on the clock King G2 is an excellent
very heads up move by alireza in bullet
you want to eliminate long-term tactics
like you don't want to constantly have
to think about preventing the same move
over and over again and that is why I
take this thing out of any potential
Rook takes G3 related ideas now alireza
just has the chance to develop a massive
Queen side attack with Queen E2
yeah this bishop I mean talk about a
long-term pin it even added The Rook to
the pin as well it's a longer shish
kebab we man some shish kebaby very nice
right now I'd go for a nice little hero
sandwich
or sorry Knight C4 maybe not yeah E4 is
hanging and you just take it's hard to
nail in that final nail in the coffin
somehow black is teetering on the brink
on the queen side but still holding on
much like the last game and we know how
that turned out
maybe Queen G7 to once again have every
piece lined up against something that's
defended
yeah I was thinking about that actually
I think he's got to go Queen G7 yeah
it's nice not but there's that exchange
sack that we're so familiar with Knight
D5 is a cute little move
I like it it had a good air to it
Queen A3 is like those Prospectors who
would try to go to California like six
years after the Gold Rush like all you
have are little specks of dust on C3
yeah this Rook takes H4 it looked a
little different than the last Rook
takes H4 I have to say
yeah now there will be oh no pieces to
put on H4
I was gonna say Knight D5 and then I was
like wait a minute wondering my entire
night there
well this is getting
he needs like a full-time yeah that's
such a really nasty move for G5 so smart
it's just no threat I mean that King on
G2 is safe as houses
84 and that might spell the end of the
game Knight F3
yeah you mean
spell the end of the g-a-m-e oh my gosh
what a trick
yeah nice nice move there remain calm
after Queen uh age five realized there
was actually zero threats yeah yeah
everything is defended like 600 times
even if he took on F3 there and
delivered a check on H2 there was still
nothing
okay tied again
yeah and this is the thing about bullet
is like uh after you know two three
games get put together okay start
talking about momentum start talking
about the match shifting but one game
from either player I don't think you can
really get ahead of yourself
um because remember on Drake and Came
Out Swinging the first game it's like
unbelievable and then game two ferrugia
just kind of puts it all to bed so these
guys are so strong you will see it go
back and forth yeah
and uh we've seen this opening once or
twice in this match Knight B5 oh that
was a big Miss by farusha allowing this
Mass trade and after the end of it
White's got the bishop parent Black's
got a really bad structure all the rest
of just kind of fell asleep on that move
yeah and this is something that I mean
he had his eye on literally every move
in Blitz and he never allowed it but in
bullet you're just moving that much
quicker and not not remembering the
basic things a huge chance for andrekin
this is a massive position but yeah
positionally this is just so bad there's
so many weak squares so many
infiltration points for for white and
black has virtually no activity because
the knights are just so restricted by
white pawns alirez is trying to generate
some activity b4a5 Maybe
and get the C3 Square for his Knight so
he's he's doing a pretty good job
actually of making the most of this
position what is Knight F3 is he doing
yeah he's going to D2 but it's
definitely slow and takes some Knight C3
I mean way too passive for Dimitri
agreed F3 I think is long overdue
I think alireza has essentially
equalized I mean it's still anybody's
game great move by andraken there
targeting but Bishop takes B4 runs into
Knight A2
so it's not even a possibility here
there's no threat and what a move by
alireza he realizes it amazing
now you can play it and then go Rook A1
but at the end of that line I think
black gets two pieces for a rook in a
pretty good position
huh yeah you feel like this Pawn's an
issue but with the Knight coming to C6
alireza is getting out of this and the
ex you can feel the position sort of
flipping on its head right now yep and
as the clock continues to dwindle we
know that alireza is the heavy favorite
in all out time scrambles really in any
position E6 good move covering something
I like Knight B1 right it's a weird move
but I want to get that night the heck
out of there all right Dimitri Hamilton
at least this one wasn't blender well
but the blender might come in a couple
moves here because there's so many
threats here Knight takes B3 is a
massive threat King C2 Rook A2 is
Checkmate and he overreacts he sacks The
Exchange and if black can get the Rook
out of A1 and extricated black will be
technically winning here Bishop F5 no I
see six
yeah there's Bishop B1 to fully remove
the Rook not anymore God look at these
Maneuvers from all there's a knight c6a7
B5 and a bullet game seriously
and H5 definitely that H4 Pawn is going
to be the reason why why black has
serious chances here
this is unplayable in a bullet game for
white unplayable Bishop A4 release
what a blow
yeah the
accuracy from Ali Reza just kicked in
there
yeah this is impossible
to give up a draw would be one thing but
after having played Knight B5 and
getting a dream end game
to have it turned around on you like
that losing with the white pieces this
might be a pivotal moment in this match
and alireza has a golden opportunity to
put his mark on the match with a victory
in the next game
and you're seeing why is he playing yeah
you're seeing something interesting it's
almost uh that on draken feels like uh
Ali Reza could run up a score maybe with
with more time to play because he's the
one playing on even though he's about to
lose
yeah it's either that or he's tilted but
Dimitri is not exactly a you know heavy
tilter so I think you know his demeanor
is almost like he still has a chance
like he's playing for something he's
like 65 and opposition
like if you didn't see the position and
you just saw the camera you'd be like oh
farooza looks pretty stressed here I
think in general when you look at chess
players on camera it is literally
impossible to say if they're up a queen
down a queen happy sad you know like
their emotions do not correspond in any
way shape or form to this happenings on
the board or actually they correspond
perfectly negatively yeah
exact inverse correlation
exactly right another Italian and a
third setup by Dimitri we saw him
play the G5 line we saw
um an approach with D5 and now we're
seeing the more traditional symmetrical
system where both sides get their
Knights to the king side and black
generally goes Bishop E6 at some point
and contests whites light squared Bishop
ooh spicy uh yeah inviting everything
here 95.95 and D3 would hang that
classic
Knight F4 Queen F6 kind of massing the
pieces on the king side I like this
approach particularly in a bullet game
yep agree with that there are some plans
that you know you might like in general
but in a bullet game you're like yup
I'll I'll take some of that
he needs to take a knight on F4 D5
um
it looks like you know a risky move here
I mean I have to say Knight F4 looks
tempting man alirez is like you know a
pilot when you enter turbulence like
passengers are all grabbing their seats
and he's just breezily up just hitting a
few bumps here ladies and gentlemen
nothing to be concerned about Bishop C2
you know Knight F5 is being prepared I
don't know how I don't know how he can
be so calm here but he's like I've seen
seen this before Knight takes Pawn takes
and yeah it looks pretty safe I'm not
gonna lie and again just a whole board
awareness I love the way that alireza
has used both sides of the board
throughout this match look at this
Knight C4 move on the queen side and
then a move on the king side and that
kind of play is so hard to answer
without spending loads of time Dimitri
down to 14 seconds he's in trouble yet
again but still trying Queen F3 careful
if you're alireza
yep it's easy to miss that you know just
go Bishop routine he missed it Queen F3
Queen takes C3 missed the two
they both missed it I mean god dude this
is fine but that is a massive miss queen
F3 to C3
I don't get it at all I thought that's
why he played G4 it's like the only
purpose of that move
he's worse here Rook D7 look
yeah Rook D1 is coming and I don't think
you can actually
get like you can't
establish your pieces properly here
that right there might have been a
decider because not only does it take C7
he literally just went from winning on
the spot to losing on the spot uh
takes in Bishop E3 and the G4 Pawn that
is the ultimate Twist of evil irony that
is the pawn which would have won the
game now it's the pawn which ultimately
will lose you the game okay he goes
after the queen side instead yeah it's
over good enough Bishop C5 for instance
or this A5 just push the pawn A7
very professional approach
and such a good bullet approach because
you really just picked the simplest way
to do it just promote and win the game
and it's a two-point lead and it comes
at the worst possible moment for Dimitri
that's right uh I would say we're
getting close to the territory of oh
wait we had it on there yeah the
governor we're not quite there though I
will say that I think on vacant's got
one or two more games in him and how
about a an actual London here we go sure
that is music to your ears probably came
a little bit later than you would have
hoped but
London nonetheless we had a jabobil in
an earlier by faruga now it's Dimitri's
turn
uh to pay homage to the capital of
England
Chief or
wow Bishop C3 here almost looks you just
like play it to force Bishop F1 just to
say I told you yeah
it feels like the wheels are starting to
come off it just doesn't look like
Dimitri's getting the types of positions
where he excels particularly in a bullet
game
this is too easy for alireza I don't
know anybody who excels in a position
like this it's just a terrible position
it's like there's no Specialists out
there yeah I would maybe got a commski
would
or at least I would sit for 40 seconds
and then repeat but that's true
he took that jar real fast yeah that's
that's interesting
um because I I think his position was
good enough to play or like he should
have sat there
um but I I am surprised to not see him
play that position out I think black had
a big Edge yeah it's kind of a role
reversal like I could see Dimitri doing
that in a situation where he's leading
this does give white uh Dimitri a new
lease on life because if he had lost
that one I mean that would have been a
three-point match then now he plays the
Sicilian he's maybe got a shot he needs
to deliver on his tactical chances
though he cannot miss another one of
those
you know wins on a golden platter like
Queen F3
interesting decision
um for white to play Queen F2 he's
basically saying okay I'm not going to
Castle Queen side you got me uh El
castle kingside
and very calm very safe play by alireza
he's just slightly better here exactly
what you want in a bullet game easy to
play position no weaknesses
just very compact
I wonder if he's gonna Castle Queen side
I feel like King side is the overall
safer approach if you just don't want to
take a risky position
I think he doesn't want to take a risky
position
this is remarkable you know you're on
the broadcast for a reason
I know my insights are unparalleled
on draken's position just doesn't
it's not doing much but he's kind of
bled White's clock dry it all these
decisions that Reza had to make like
wear to Castle and how to position his
minor pieces he's now down to 20 seconds
the issue is he can play very very
quickly and the price of a move is not
high it's almost impossible to blunder
here
well he might have found a way
okay we trade in a draw
that always benefits alireza although I
will say that I think andrekin's playing
for a bit more here I do like his
position great structure and the
Sicilian is like you're always happy to
get to an end game as black and when the
pawn on B5 follows the silt and it just
did the silver lining is that black gets
a lot of prospects for his Rook Rook AB8
will win the B4 Pawn back although
you've got to be careful Knight C3 and
Knight D5 is a bit of a cold shower yeah
and now has established yeah he's
established this protected Pawn on B5
yeah you can take this but ah this does
not feel like what you want to have
11 minutes on the match clock and this
one's gonna bleed
at least one would think another minute
off the match clock bad news for Dimitri
I don't see him winning this game no and
it's just uncomfortable at this point
yeah he needs to hold a draw at least
five
and just hang out here as Ali Reza these
are eating this is eating a lot of time
off the clock and I mean how long was
this game I'm looking at the matchbox is
definitely at least four minutes
yeah this is exactly what you don't want
one of these like long drawn out games
that never seem to end Dimitri just
needs to repeat moves he's
he's avoiding repetition okay
somehow it's still not three-time
repetition we play G3 is white like keep
the game going
so it ended up taking another minute off
the clock we're down to exactly 10
minutes
we remind you that if a game starts and
there's even one second on the match
clock it does count for the overall
score so the problem at this point isn't
that Dimitri doesn't have enough time
it's just the way that this bullet
segment has been going feels like
alireza is completely in control but
that could change in one game
yeah so what do we have here on breaking
with the white pieces 10 minutes
it's just that the way things have been
going I it's not that oh they've been
draws alirez has been saving amazing
positions like unbelievable it's
actually just been well on draken hasn't
got anything going nope after that first
bullet game that was the Lone you know
bright spot you know otherwise very
dreary bullet segment where he's been
stumbling over himself
whoa
that is an angry move Bishop H6 but does
it actually do anything
it barks very loudly but does it carry
ing
Bishop F2 yeah covering G5 look at that
view
this looks like pretty decent theory for
black because I imagine H6 Queen G5 uh
will happen defensively or maybe Queen
H5 basically a queen trade and I kind of
like black structure slightly better
he's also got all of the time that he
started with and Dimitri's down to 16
seconds yeah that feels like it feels
like Dimitri's completely on the back
foot in all these games
that is correct
not the right feeling to have when you
need the results when you need the
points to come back yeah he's not even
you know like really approaching a win
but again all it takes one little
blunder
uh I hate these uh these games that he's
getting it's like 94 Knight takes Rook
takes you know maybe it'll be a draw but
it'll be some long draw where he's
really gotta earn it
H5 all the rest is just pushing pawns on
both the H5 B5 rookie uh oh I think
Dimitri's got a fight for a draw here
and he has to make it because a loss
basically ends the match at this point
that's right
B3 just trampolining The Rook from one
side to the other beautiful command of
maneuvering by alireza but okay
Dimitri's holding on here
is Rook F3 is also kind of a nice move
um if he wants he can connect the pawns
again
and again we're gonna get one of these
long end games that are going to milk
another minute off the clock
that's exactly what we're gonna get and
so I think that sets us up for basically
a must-win game next uh provided that he
can of course draw this
yeah which
you never know it's a bullet game
and to be fair alireza could lose this
as well probably just uh as easily as on
Dragon could but yes when I see B3 from
alireza that tells me that he almost
wants to keep the game going a little
bit he wants to get his King to F5 and
Dimitri has to make sure that he can
meet King F5 with a check on E5 or C5
and that's what he's doing just keep the
rook in the vicinity of the third rank
but yeah this is taking forever and
we're down to like six and a half
minutes we are in firm us to win
territory after this game
once
there we go
and here we go Dimitri has black six
minutes uh based on how long these games
have been going Daniel like four or five
minutes guess what you might have to win
this we might have time for two only two
more games
okay another accelerated dragon or not
even accelerated just dragon
oh there that was accelerated yeah that
pace of the moves was accelerated but
the opening is not I don't know if I
like
this H5 setup this Dragon door type
setup because it's so easy to play for
white so Ali Reza can repeat exactly
what he did in the previous game or he
can go long castle and go just go for
the kill in this game
I think it's so much smarter to short
Castle just
um game
uh decision but uh what was that he's
the purest you know I predict on
draken's moves not for rouge's that's
for sure I mean we have essentially a
Mainline dragon with a black Pawn on H5
which gives the position of someone
unconventional air
I feel like unconventional you've
already you've sold farrugia
unconventional I'm in all right sign me
up yeah the unconventional Club
he's very good at handling those
unorthodox type of positions and I mean
he's he's down on time so look if you're
on draken are you complaining you've got
opposite sized castling you're up on
time you're launching an attack I think
this is the best you can hope for I
haven't gotten the memo on why you can't
take that pawn on B5 and just go Knight
A3 Knight C4
okay Bishop E3 allows Queen B7 that was
an unnecessary move by furusia which
actually improves the placement of black
screen now A4 could potentially come
with great effect just ripping open the
B file he has to play A4 here yeah A4
and 94 there was something oh my gosh
that was a chance that A4 was almost
winning for black according to the
engine but he's not even looking for
these tactics at this point I think he's
just he's almost given up hope mentally
a little bit mentally defeated like if
the if the win presents itself it might
capitalize but it needs to be more
obvious than that and now for just
loading up the defensive forces on the
queen side everything's protected I
really like the arrangement of White's
Knights the Knight on A4 can jump to B6
the other night is guarding C2 and the
last attempt by andrakin Rook takes C2
is his idea what a tactic that's
actually amazing and this could work
take it and take B3
yeah give it a go because you're gonna
grab this Pawn okay probably it was
important to take this
Crazy Light position I like the moves
though like this is the way to fight so
so Black is Black has what about to have
three pawns for the piece but the bigger
problem is that White's Knights are now
stranded on the queen side where they
really need to be is the other side of
the board and that's what he's trying to
do Knight after about E5 I was wondering
about E5 Rook takes H4 Bishop G2 Bishop
G2 black is winning H3
fun it's time to go
it's time to go it's time to win Rook G4
or Rook F3
C4 and Rook G1 Maybe
I don't know like Rook D3 but it should
do the trick here yeah so he just wanted
to cover G3 with the Rook I guess like
on he's taking everything
not me on Rook A4
very very good
beautiful what an on-demand win that
last trip with the Rook take C2 ice in
his veins that was like he really did uh
go all up because I think farrugia was
just about to add like too many
Defenders that is just like a blob like
you just can't Frack it
um
now that was really really impressive so
guess what Dania
um unless we get a really weird quick
draw this this is what it's all come
down to it as all this is what the SEC
is all about must win situations
and crazy narratives can he win two
games in a row on demand in alirez's
preferred time control and he will have
to somehow unbalance this position to
actually get a chance exactly
yeah it couldn't be like more boring
nope I don't like this
no I just like how are you gonna win
this game and look at it oh oh no G4 and
Knight D2 is a fork I swear I think you
alluded to this video to the show I did
but oh man the good news for white is
that he has some of these dark squares
yep as compensation for the exchange so
it's definitely not over there will
definitely be compensation here yeah
okay Queen B6 Knight D7 oh my God and
then Queen B5 check I guess but there's
a check but I you know that's what you
want as as white the pieces are all over
the dark squares yeah Queen E7 Knight D7
okay now Knight takes C6 and 97.
borussia's gonna give up his Queen for
that night and try to force a Perpetual
check Maybe
or maybe he's just going opposite
Bishops and saying hey this is the
reality beat me but now that the match
clock becomes a very serious
consideration Dimitri has to keep an eye
on it if there's a minute left and what
alireza wants to do is milk this down to
zero and then for some sort of Perpetual
check such a decision here I think King
F7 is like
okay big big moment Gotta Go Gotta Go
Gotta Go 45 seconds left Dimitri has to
play Fast not because of his time
situation but because of the match clock
he might run out of time
this is so unpleasant Rook F7 hourly res
is just better I think
he might lose this what do you do about
this at least he's going out on his
shield here
foreign
25 seconds on the match clock and the
problem now is alireza basically has a
draw on demand that he can make whenever
that match clock will show zero I think
Dimitri realizes it he has to go for the
win now F3 probably only try only move
I'll take some light squares he needs a
miracle the match clock is down to zero
this is gonna be the last game
can he get a miracle
he's just giving up the rest of his
punts trying to reach some sort of
imbalance Queen takes oh
chance now he's got a d-pawn
but oh Bishop E7 and D6 is coming
oh wait a second
real chances here three seconds Ali Reza
checking White's King this way and that
way can it escape the checks I think so
yes it can
A4 D6 A3 D7 A2 oh my God Bishop takes F6
check but that's only a draw
I don't think he's got anything here
oh oh
no the bishop is covering the Rook this
is dead that's it
it's a drop
you can play King D1 though yeah you
know
you can get yourself mated if you if you
wish yeah
that's the match
I mean
yeah here you go King D1 this was he
does it good why did alireza do that he
found that one no way to keep this game
going rugby two queen C3 oh this is
incredible oh it's losing Queen is
winning oh he missed it he had Queen
it's winning 24
000 times
went nice but it's still a draw
oh my God how about the house this game
but now he's gonna flag he's gonna flag
no he holds it God he's gonna hold it
this is just nonsense this is not ending
Dimitri was actually winning
there was a win on the board
oh my God now you cannot show it now
we're in the thick of it but no but oh
my God I cannot believe this
he's still trying but it black just has
too many squares and it's a draw
and oh my goodness what a sigh of relief
for Ali Reza he made that as difficult
as possible he found the one square that
you can go to with your king to get
yourself in zoo song and the big moment
where Dimitri was winning Queen D4 but
here's the thing King B1 now Queen B4
that's the Intermezzo that he missed and
and Sim yeah so the idea is Queen E4 you
promote to a knight and you just always
have this drawing mechanism
yeah and this just wins Queen B4 was
like such an important Victory uh uh
would have been such an important
Victory I'm still in shock as Ali Reza
Wins Batman there's a beautiful line
Rook B2 Queen takes C4 check and then
you staircase down to C1 that's actually
the only way to win that resulting
position
oh my God
so let's pull up a board here
we have to we have to show you guys
because this was just absolute Madness
at the end
um so Queen B6 was played and I think
potentially there was like already a
moment to maybe make it happen uh which
is why it's showing a Miss there but
this is the general idea instead of
Queen B4 Queen D4 check
King to B1 and instead Dania of Queen
takes Bishop it's actually Queen
B4 check
and now to take the bishop
and if the king had moved or The Rook
rather had gone to B2 and queen takes
King A1 and continue this staircase
things it doesn't end yeah there's just
every it's like the gift that keeps on
giving this position Queen D3 Queen C3
and the threat of King C1
forces black to move the king and then
Queen C1 is Checkmate that is just
illegally beautiful pattern yeah and to
think that this
happened after remember earlier when The
Rook was on C2 and the bishop was
covering it and the pawn was on H7 it's
like how the heck did this even happen
he I'd say he found the one square to
allow and literally you could put the
King on any other Square on the
chessboard but this is how the SEC match
tends to go this is just the
stereotypical epitome of an SEC match
just when you think you have a handle on
how things are gonna go the match
there's a wrinkle at you let's look at
our overall bracket we can congratulate
all the Reza farusha on only a one-point
Victory and he will face Wesley so in
the quarterfinals he will have to step
up his game if he is to defeat uh the
stalwart one of the most consistent
stable annoying players in the SEC
Wesley convincingly defeated Lebanon
Ronin that is gonna be
an incredible match this was an
incredible match of mine
it really was incredible like uh we were
going over the tie break rules at the
beginning and so glad we did because it
it so very nearly happened in a match
that a lot of people could have expected
as a blowout on draken once again proves
that he's no pushover and quite
literally could have pulled it to at the
very minimum a tide match and a tie
break fuja such a deserved winner but we
just got a treat today Daniel this was
such an entertaining match we saw some
insane blunders from you know the best
players in the world Jack made in one
Queens hanging loose tactics everywhere
but ultimately fuja did get it done in
his time control the bullet portion and
one of those watershed moments uh is
going to be our coinbase Savvy move of
the day let's go take a look at the
Savvy moves presented by coinbase this
was a key moment in the match where
Dimitri and draken had a very good
handle on things he was leading for the
entire first half of the match and then
out of a clear blue sky he's out playing
alireza farusia and in one of the most
important moments in the match
things turn around in the span of three
seconds in this position Reza plays the
move Queen A3 looks like a pretty
inconspicuous normal move Dimitri
continues with this plan and plays Rook
H4 to C4 now he sees one threat which is
that Knight takes E2 check doesn't any
longer work because of Queen takes E2
and the Rooks defend each other but he
misses our coinbase Savvy move of the
diamond I'll let you do the honors
absolutely double exclamation mark and
shall we say perhaps not match deciding
but definitely tipped the scales because
From This Moment Queen takes C1 what a
move you're you're losing the entire
queen or so it would seem but Knight
takes E2 wins the queen back and you got
a rook and you only had to give up a
knight for it this led to a win for Ali
Reza and uh Danny is such an important
moment in the match it felt like
ferrugia never looked back from here it
really did I mean the adventures did not
stop there Dimitri even had a draw at
one point believe it or not but
ultimately alireza converted his
advantage and equalized the score in the
match and went on to a scintillating
Victory we'd like to think coinbase uh
forbing the presenting sponsor of the
speed Chess Championship
and we would like to ask you not to go
anywhere because we will be having an
interview with alireza farusha the
deserving winner we will go set alireza
up and we will ask him all about his
thoughts on this match and his next SEC
matches we'll be back with Ali Reza in
just a couple seconds
[Music]
is coming to chess.com
enchant your pieces with one of two
spells jump or freeze there start with
two jump spells and five free spells
which we charge after five moves you may
test your spare whenever you wish before
making a regular chest move jump is a
spell cast to one square wherein if
there is a piece on that square other
pieces can jump over the Charmed piece
the freeze spell is cashed over a three
by three square area and the pieces in
this area are temporarily Frozen in
place
and bang your powers of Chess and
surgery to defeat your opponent
see what supercell and chess.com have
cooked up in our new variant spell chess
dropping on September 1st
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase
alireza farusha has defeated Dimitri on
draken in a really interesting
topsy-turvy match that came down to the
last game all your rest of this match
didn't necessarily start the way you
wanted it to you were facing a deficit
for most of the first half how did you
steal yourself and Coach yourself to
overcome that lead and can you share
your thoughts on your play in this match
overall
yeah I was not happy with the start of
course the five plus one I expected more
but I made a lot of blunders and he
played great so he deserved to win but
um by three points it was too much I
think and after I had to play really
good in three plus one to come back so
and still he played really good but then
I got lucky at some point I got some
tactics there and I managed to tie it up
for bullet and then I think I was
favored if we were going to Bullet a bit
tight match so I was expecting to be
down two three points for bullet and
then fight it out but it taken it turned
out good in Blitz
yeah it it really did feel uh Ali Reza
like early on that he had the upper hand
but you always did a good job of keeping
the match close uh I want to ask
probably what everyone is thinking
um what was going on when you brought
your king to A1 at the end of the match
like did you realize that you were
risking losing the game did you know
that you actually were dead lost in that
final position or at least win the game
could have checked you with your King on
A1 there there were a few moments
if for some reason I said like there's
five minutes left I don't know why I
thought that and then I was trying
really hard to win but it was it was
just stupid to not check the clock I
checked the clock but somehow maybe I
saw just five I don't know what happened
but yeah it was definitely stupid and it
was desperate it was desperate trying to
win but then of course I think he was
winning at some point it was not easy
with this Knight trick he missed
probably making nights so then I think
there in that specific position is draw
but the other positions is probably
winning
yeah
fair enough well there were a lot of
surprises in this match
um we've got some feature chat questions
for you uh Ali Reza I'm gonna start with
uh Max linick who asks at one point you
were looking uh intently out of the
window
um during one of the breaks wherever you
are do you have a nice view that you
were taking inspiration from during the
break
no I was just looking at myself because
here it's a night so the mirror reflects
I was just looking at myself thinking I
don't I don't have this view I couldn't
see outside
yeah
that's that's the answer that we were
definitely not expecting but glad we got
and so I'm sure Max will be satisfied
with that there's another feature chat
question uh from Deborah denti which is
uh alireza I mean obviously we're
excited watching you in this tournament
can't wait to watch you more but what's
your next over the board tournament that
maybe you can tell us about
I've been playing Isle of Man Grand
series it is on 25th 24th of October
that's my next tournament
all right
guys show well your next SCC match
alireza final question for you will be
against Wesley so
um you are no stranger to facing Wesley
across many formats uh can you share
your brief thoughts on your next SCC
challenge in the quarterfinals
yeah I think it's it will be a really
different match the andrekin's style is
really short when attacking and whiskeys
and of course different so
um I expect to be a close match at least
I hope but then I will try my best to to
to
play better than today and we'll see
what happens
yeah
well Ali Reza we will watch that match
very intently uh this was a real blast
to compensate and to watch
congratulations on defeating Dimitri on
Drake and best of luck in Isle of Man
but obviously before that in your
quarterfinal match against Wesley so
thank you
congrats thanks guys thank you
well another
riveting SCC match is in the books we've
got three out of four quarterfinalists
already determined Hikaru Hall Saran and
now alireza farusha faces Wesley so
yeah some incredible matches coming up
carwana abdusitorov and of course
vashiella gravigan's gukesh to determine
nihal's opponent
yeah and so far uh as you know the the
fans can see from looking at that
bracket the favorites have won all their
matches so you know we're we're waiting
to find out if there's going to be any
names that we might not have expected to
make it to the next round but I mean I
think the matches just get more and more
mouth-watering as the rounds progress in
this competition Dania yeah and one
thing that I've learned over the years
compensating the SEC is you can really
never predict the outcome of imagining
we thought that this map smarter chest
thought this match would be a blowout I
mean Ali Reza was actually losing for
most of the match and then it's true the
way that he came back there were like
two stages right first he tied the match
and then in the bullet he got that lead
the lead was whittled down to one
Dimitri on draken could have won that
final game to force overtime and
ultimately it ended with a night under
promotion what a conclusion to the match
amazing Aman Allah asked the mic to you
one last time for your uh for your final
thoughts before before we wrap up
well uh to be quite Frank uh Dania I
think ending that with a night promotion
and alireza thinking that there was five
minutes on the clock and that he was
playing for the win but actually he was
playing to potentially lose himself the
entire match I mean it just doesn't get
more perfect than that that summarizes
this match such an entertaining one it
came down to literally the last game The
Last Moment the last seconds of the last
game so I don't think the fans could
have asked for anything more than that
and alireza has always just such a great
interview such a funny guy and uh on
draken I mean what can we say he always
delivers a class match he's a Class Act
and he absolutely is alireza alluded to
himself you know at some point could
have maybe should have and certainly at
least deserved to win this match so a
great great match by both players and
happy to have the call with you Daniel
likewise is a funny guy but uh so are
you this was a great pleasure to
compensate we wanted to remind you that
if you're asking for another
entertaining SCC match in like 2 days
from now maybe just to give you one day
of recovery well you're gonna get one
Sunday 9 A.M Eastern six in the morning
Pacific time and 3 P.M central European
Standard time we will have dingley Wren
taking on the Indian Phenom Arjun
aragaisi absolutely unmissable weekend
SEC action it's pretty early in the
morning so if you're in the U.S you can
watch it from your bed put it on the
television and enjoy yourself I'll be
bringing you that call alongside Simon
Williams Amman was a great pleasure to
bring the SCC commentary with you today
we'd like to thank our amazing
production team working behind the
scenes and on that note the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase
concludes for the day we will see you
for the next match on Sunday goodbye
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
questions
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign